a Canadian court has actually issued an
injunction on honking horns in Ottawa I
kid you not they have banned honking
your horn wow it's kind of crazy to
think the honking is working that's it
literally just pulling them in a car and
going honk honk has the entire political
establishment losing their minds people
pretending to get hit by trucks falling
over and flopping on the ground in the
streets and according to reporting from
Andy no actually having anti-fugettin
SUVs and hit people man the honking
really is making these people lose their
minds but if you watch the videos it's
regular people they're celebrating
they're dancing and they're saying no
and it's spreading now there's rumors
circulating at least I think it's
rolling stone reporting this that
Republicans want truckers to shut down
the Super Bowl okay well we'll get into
all that stuff there's a lot going on
with the great honking you've got police
arresting people seizing gas cans so
this will be interesting subject to talk
about we also have Rumble the video
platform offering Joe Rogan 100 million
dollars over four years to leave Spotify
and join their platform I believe they
have the funds to do this they had that
that special purpose acquisition company
merger thing they're going to be getting
about 400 million it's been reported but
I don't see why Joe would leave the
platform I I just don't see why he would
do it for the same amount of money the
concern is I guess rumbles like Joe you
know come over here and you won't be
censored and Joe's like they're telling
me not to say the n-word and I don't
think Joe's going to want to jump from
rum from Spotify to rumble for the sake
of that you know that doesn't make sense
but we'll talk about everything that's
going on there we got Peter Thiel
stepping down from Facebook to focus on
campaigning for Republicans so this
should be really really interesting plus
some news about
Facebook stock in the Olympics so
joining us today to talk about all this
is Greg price thanks for having me you
want to introduce yourself I'm Greg
price I work for a company called
xstrategies LLC we're a digital strategy
firm and we work with a bunch of uh
conservative members of Congress and
candidates and non-profits and super
Pacs uh we work to elect America First
candidates and unelect the Rhinos
um yeah before that I was at the I was
at the Daily Caller before that too I'm
gonna elect the Rhinos Sheamus here I am
Seamus Coughlin Creator Freedom Tunes uh
we actually plan on releasing a cartoon
tomorrow if you guys want to head over
there hit that subscribe button get
notified and I'm once again back to have
a conversation with my friends about
some interesting issues lovely amazing
humans Monday night coming at you from
Maryland oh Ohio I was going to say
that's where I'm from originally
Maryland United States there's two
states not a city what's up uh what's up
Canada I'm with you tonight baby you're
500 miles away and I hear you loud and
clear I love it I'm loving all this talk
of the honking I'm really excited to
hear more about what's going on in
Canada it is a little bit dark at the
moment but hopefully it brightens up
we'll see what happens before we get
started my friends we have an awesome
sponsor who helps make all of this
possible virtual Shield go to
surfinginternetsafe.com and pick up your
copy of virtual Shield virtual private
network service to help keep you safe
while you browse the internet I just
wanna I just want to stress this point
for for everybody
when when the January 6 committee
started going after people like Alex
Jones Alex Jones flat out came out and
said that they had tons of his private
information tons of his his text
messages a lot of stuff
they're going to these companies these
providers and saying just give us their
information and they're like sure no
problem now normally that's a violation
of our privacy rights but well you give
up your rights when you work with these
third-party companies so get a virtual
private network service like virtual
shield and it helps keep your your data
safe so again go to
surfinginternetsafe.com
and they say
virtual virtual Shield lets you browse
the web completely anonymously so big
name isps and other third parties will
not be able to monitor your activity
when using their VPN your traffic is
routed through secure and encrypted
servers that means any restriction
censorship blocks on the internet are
bypassed you can enjoy browsing on a
fast reliable and secure network and
it's completely free for 30 days it
works on Mac Windows iPhone iPad Android
Chrome virtual Shield does all the work
for you your entire connection becomes
secure private and encrypted it routes
your internet through advanced encrypted
servers across the globe to prevent your
internet service provider from being
able to track your internet uh traffic
there you go uh no security is perfect
nothing is but this is a basic layer of
defense and it also basically has you
saying when you get a service like this
I expect privacy and that actually has
some legal weight as well so again
surfinginternetsafe.com shout out
virtual Shield thanks for the support
but don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member help support the show
support the work we do support all of
our journalists as a member you'll get
access to exclusive members podcast best
of this show that go up Monday through
Monday through Thursday at 11 PM so when
we wrap the live show we record for an
additional half an hour with our guests
and those go up on the website as a
member you'll get to watch those and it
helps make it helps keep the light on
keep it keep all the lights on now we
also have a bunch of stickers and shirts
you can see we have the free hunk hunk
premium t-shirt the free hunk hunk
premium sweater we have hunka Boot and
fine boot stickers and free honk honk
stickers as well if you buy this stuff
you'll be supporting the message but the
funds go to supporting the work we do if
you guys want to directly support the
great honking you can go to their give
send go and I want to make sure that
distinction is clear because if you
prefer to support the movement you know
this this is our merch just we wanted to
make something that celebrated and
supported the idea of the great honking
of course the free Hong Kong is modeled
after the free Hong Kong flag so you can
check that out if you're so interested
but let's get into that first big story
from the week.com court issues 10-day
ban on honking in downtown
Ottawa a Canadian judge issued attend a
injunction Monday Banning protesters
protesting truckers from honking their
horns in downtown Ottawa quote tooting a
horn is not an expression of of any
great thought I'm aware of Justice Hugh
McLean of the Ottawa Superior Court said
he also said the abandoned honking would
not Rob demonstrators of their right to
protest a convoy of truckers and other
demonstrators protesting Canada's
covid-19 policies entered on January
29th where they've been for some time
let me just let me just uh answer you
know respond to this year Justice Hugh
McLean honking absolutely is an
expression of a great thought he doesn't
understand memes but more importantly
the state this is Canada by the way it's
not the U.S so they can have their
backwards garbage policies or whatever
the state should not be deciding what is
someone's expression what comes next now
people are saying I'll just yell hunk
I'll just get a megaphone and just yell
honk into it okay well I think this is a
ridiculous this is ridiculous but I will
say it shows well the great honking has
worked it's worked to the point where a
court has had to issue one of the most
ridiculous injunctions I've ever heard
of honking is forbidden sounds like
they're going to try and get them out of
there now in the next 10 days they're
like let's buy ourselves a little time
we'll see if we can get out if it can't
nine and a half days from now they'll
issue another ban for 10 more days or
whatever you know only 15 days to slow
the spread of these truckers uh all
around the country
I just I just think it's funny because
it's Canada it's Canada honking is
banned it's just this works on so many
levels right first people are posting
memes where they're like who would have
thought the answer to clown world would
have been honking I know it's just so
good and then you have it's happening in
Canada of all places and they got the
goose yeah so it's just like that we we
we live in some kind of constructed
reality I got a simulation let me put
this on a table I I've been thinking a
lot about this honking is it can be very
it you could argue that it's a kind of
noise weapons are real you can destroy
someone with excessive amounts of noise
you can hurt someone with that the CIA
knows it they work with those things
um so a lot of noise is kind of can be
weaponized now it's then so like are
they so apparently these people are
honking and they're violating maybe
Civil Rights noise violations but for
for the Canadian government to start to
violate their human rights of like food
and fuel seems like that's stoking the
bear well this is the Great Canadian
bear well this is a Canadian government
that was we know was seizing their
gasoline too like though that you know
they there's there's this uprising of of
workers that's and it's it's pissing off
the people in power in Canada and it
seems that they'll they'll go to Great
Lengths in order to shut them up
yeah no I mean I agree with you they're
basically placing sanctions on these
people and then they're arguing that
honking is an act of violence
honk yeah I've been wondering I think
you're I think you're not quite rolling
a one on this one yeah you got like
three or something no maybe a ten okay
you know I I think there's a guy who's
got a train horn and people are laughing
about it because it's triggering people
I'm like dude I gotta be honest the
train horn might be a little much like
honking your horn is honking her and
everybody's got one but mounting a train
horn to a vehicle and then blaring it
bro like yeah I mean that that's that's
not helping your cause out you know
honking your horn is annoying protest as
AOC says are supposed to make people
uncomfortable so honking your horn hey
man more power to you uh if they say hey
guy you get you brought a train horn to
downtown Ottawa I'd I'd be like yeah
dude that's like come on it's a little
much isn't it I mean it's funny but it's
when all the trucks come together they
create like a mega horn which is like
way worse than well the way louder than
a train horn I I'm I don't know what to
do because I support these truckers
implicitly I mean if I'm thinking I want
to I want want to help the cause but I
will still acknowledge that this noise
can be used as a form of violence and so
I understand kind of both sides of this
yeah
hold on hold on like what do you mean by
violence yeah like you can harm like if
I take a big loudspeaker and put it next
to your head and yeah do it you'll be
like ah and then you'll hurt your
hearing and then it might even start to
make you make you angry which makes it
stressed well it can be really annoying
but it's not like the truckers are going
he supports the mandates get him and
then like putting their head next to the
horn and honking so they go deaf I mean
they're just they're they're honking
their horns in a way that makes people
uncomfortable you also have to consider
is that these truckers themselves are
here day in and day out and it's going
to get annoying to them on some level so
I I think they can self-regulate here I
think it's insane the Canadian
government would tell them they're not
able to express themselves in this way
like I could like I could see if you're
a citizen in Ottawa and living in
downtown Ottawa and all day every day
all you hear is Hong Kong honk I could
see how that would get annoying at the
same time it's not like they're burning
your buildings down like in other
protests that we've seen before so I
could see how that would be annoying but
like but the government but like did the
government step in like this like in the
summer of 2020 in Canada or in the
United States well how bad were the
riding how bad was the riding in Canada
though I honestly don't know well the
movement was everywhere yeah but it
might not have been as bad as America
but it was
black Canadian lives matter like
smashing windows and burning buildings
and everything probably not as bad as
America but the movement was you know
they wouldn't but it but like you know
it's again it's the politics behind this
I don't think you know the you know the
I just searched the Ottawa on Twitter I
saw this video I think yesterday which
is what brought this up in my mind is a
guy in Ottawa got his videos like hey
guys just so you know this is what it's
like all day and it's like where just
non-stop so I understand I would go
freaking crazy if all of a sudden I on
whatever uh vax run I'd support her all
of a sudden just maddening noise all
around me yeah you know I don't care uh
you wanna know why the insurance
companies will pay for it yeah exactly
yeah yeah yeah so if you get ear damage
you got insurance what's the problem
it's a language of the unheard um
that's that's that's not actually I
don't I don't agree with that yeah no
it's a ridiculous notion yeah but uh I I
don't I don't actually care about the
discomfort of these people because as
the government was ruling by decree they
sat back and said sure and then when the
government started cracking down on the
truckers imposing will by decree on them
and the trucker said stop the people sat
in their homes and said hey I'm not
getting involved I don't care they're
doing it too in fact I'll vote for them
and Empower them and pay them money and
ensure they can keep putting their boot
on your net and then the trucker said
I'm gonna toot yeah Hong Kong another
life
no sorry buddy Ian I mean you're
absolutely right that it is extremely
annoying and if these people are outside
of my window honking I would be annoyed
as well but at the same time if it's a
question of whether we're going to allow
a group of people to be annoyed or allow
group people to have their rights
violated I'm going to choose to let
those people be annoyed yeah you said
that was pretty insightful what you said
just a second ago Tim about how like
because I'm thinking about now the
German citizens when they supported just
allowed the Nazis to do their thing and
just stood by and let it happen when the
Allied troops came in there they didn't
you know those people they had to sit by
and listen to the honking they weren't
allowed to be like stop you know you
said I just you sit and sit by and watch
tyranny take hold get ready to face some
repercussions it's not just that it's a
lot of these people are voting in these
politicians over and over again like
they vote for Trudeau they vote for the
people who are putting in place these
mandates so it's like listen we want you
to hear the repercussions of your
actions elections have consequences
Ottawa votes for these people I'm sorry
you know it's funny I'll tell you this
the people who live in Ottawa who uh who
who don't vote for this are outside
dancing in the streets cheering on the
trucks and the protests that's people
who that's people who live in Ottawa I'm
not gonna probably I live there I've
watched some of the live streams I
watched Viva fry he's got a great stream
and I've seen a lot of the videos and
there's people looking in Flags jumping
up and down they're celebrating these
are people who live in the city the
people who are screaming and complaining
about the honking are the people who did
not the people who did vote for Trudeau
and don't support the truckers I don't
care or if if look if you come out and
say you that you voted for Joe Biden I'm
going to be like okay well now you're
going to be uncomfortable uncomfortable
for having supported a man who's caused
all of these problems for us the death
of the of the civilians in Afghanistan
the rising gas prices the failing
economy there's some good things about
the economy but you can't come out and
be like we lost 2 million jobs and
brought back 1.5 so we're doing great
like no you're doing bad and if you want
to come out and be like you supported
him then I'll be like prepare to be
uncomfortable as I protest the guy you
voted in yeah no I mean I think that
when you're you're looking at this
situation
and these mandates in the fact that
these people were completely in favor of
them and that's resulted in these
protests and now they're really upset by
the honking
you kind of have to put it in
perspective ultimately what's going to
make their lives worse the
hyperinflation which is occurring uh
because we decided to print trillions of
dollars the broken supply chains the
fact that it's more difficult a
different country it's true but also our
economies are really interconnected and
if the dollar isn't doing it strongly
and we're not trading with them as much
or the supply chain is broken down in
our country that's going to affect their
lives too and a couple horns honking
outside your window day in and day out
for as long as this protest lasts is not
going to have as much of a negative
effect on their lives in the long term
the other thing you have to think about
is like the the people doing the honking
and the protesting these are the people
who during the pandemic while everyone
was all them were staying inside these
were the people who were you know
bringing you your packages to your door
bringing the supplies everywhere that
was probably more annoying than just
hearing some honks every day I'm sure
they're right dude it's amazing these
are these are people who sit inside vote
for politicians who lock everything down
and then demand the government just
gives them money yeah I saw a tweet from
this girl I don't remember who but it
was like a journalist and she was like
who do we have to appeal to to save us
from this was basically the tweet and
I'm like there's a mindset of of human
and Humanity of like where is Daddy to
save me who's gonna come fix this and
it's like dude you fix it it's you
seriously these are these people love to
be like I'm going to to vote for the
authority to do whatever they want then
go and sit back and say solve my
problems for me that vote causes
problems for everybody else who are now
dancing in the street and honking horns
not even smashing windows or anything
like that and now these people are
crying about it dude I have I have very
little sympathy I'm sorry man that's
just that's just reality these people
need to live in the real world you know
I we've talked about the fourth turning
we've talked about you know hard times
make strong men strong men make good
times good times weak men et cetera and
this is the problem with a lot of these
people who live in these big cities they
want everything done for them
they get paid ridiculous salaries for
ridiculous jobs not everybody but a lot
of them the people like in New York it's
really bad but there's a lot of city
jobs that make no sense
and they've just not experienced any
real hardship this is the first time and
I think about how crazy this is there's
that video of the guy who looks like the
pregnant man emoji have you seen this is
wearing the blue jacket and he's got
like the belly so people have put the
pregnant man emoji on them and he's like
I can't sleep I'm losing my mind or
whatever and it's like
bro calm down you know you know you know
this is the reason why I have very
little sympathy is probably because I
lived I lived on a busy street and I
hear honking all day every day non-stop
but I've also experienced you know like
actual hardship and so when I hear
people screaming and crying about
honking I'm like jeez yeah where did
they grow up inside like a fluffy padded
room that was like pastel colors with
animals painted on the wall the West
well that's a very interesting point
because Ottawa is one of the richest
cities in Canada and so for months at
least in the United States you had BLM
burning down some of the most
impoverished neighborhoods in the
country and making life impossible for
the people who live there and our media
thought that that was just fine but now
when Working Class People go into an
upper class neighborhood and honk their
horns too loudly for too long it's a
nightmare I will say as much as they are
it is a different country our culture
completely overlaps exactly so the
you've got American leftist journalists
who are on the side of the government of
Canada and then you've got American you
know libertarian conservative moderate
post-liberals who are on the side of the
great honking I I genuinely believe
you know 90 plus percent of people
support the honking you know you're
never going to convince me because I I
look at the comments on Reddit even the
astroturfing isn't working and I'm just
like I'm sorry man I don't I just won't
believe that actual Grassroots regular
leftists I don't mean online
personalities regular people that if you
go to them and say how do you feel about
the workers rising up they'd be like I
was pretty cool how do you feel about
the truckers Rising I'm glad they're
glad they're rising up against the
establishment yeah no and that's sort of
my point even though yes obviously this
is occurring in a different country our
media is going to empathize with the
upper class people who are being
inconvenienced in Canada more so than
they would lower class people in the
United States having their actual
business burnt down
I mean it goes to show that the media
speaks for the interests of you know the
ruling class and the powerful and even
in Canada where the media is actually
controlled by the government like the
media our actual government entities so
you know it's in that case they're
actually on the side of the government
and like I was looking at some of the
coverage in Canadian media and I was
like yeah you can really tell yeah it's
it's amazing one of the first articles
we read on the show it was like the far
right group that has been known for
vandalism and stealing food from the
homeless exactly exactly dude that's
just not true now there's there's the
story did you guys hear about these guys
trying to break into a building and burn
it down with people inside no and and
these left-wing activists many Americans
there well quote unquote journalists are
trying to claim that it's definitive and
proven bro it's a video of two guys we
don't know who they are they walk in a
building set fire something on the
ground and then tape the door shut and
leave that's crazy I'll rest those guys
but then they're just like this proves
it let's talk about the cops are doing
we got this story from timcast.com
police seize Fuel and supplies from
protesters and Ottawa Freedom Convoy
multiple vehicles and fuel have been
seized police said as they extend their
efforts to end the freedom Convoy
basically they're now saying anybody who
brings in fuel is going to be aiding
them it's illegal anybody who provides
material support and there's even
insinuation by Trudeau that Americans
are interfering and they want to look
into where this funding is coming from
well I don't know what Canada is going
to be able to do to an American who gave
five bucks on give send go I just don't
see them pulling anything off but yo how
insane is this getting they declared a
state of emergency and Ottawa you know I
saw a story I don't know if it's true
that Ottawa cops are exempt from the
vaccine mandates
this is how they play the game the the
enforcers get special acts it's like the
Hunger Games man
wow
yeah
no nothing to say no oh geez so much to
say uh
foreign
what was crazy to me was was seeing like
the the brand account for the Ottawa
Police Department like cheering on
gofundme's decision to you know take
this money away from the truckers you
have like this Unholy Alliance of like
the government law enforcement big
corporations you know and then you have
this like work you have these who are
just like taking away the rights of
Working Class People and you know we
complain about a lot a lot about that in
America but man like it's it's crazy
yeah like the Ottawa Police just
cheering this on is there a word for
that when the government and big
corporations starts with are working
together to control yeah yeah
the f word
yeah so earlier you mentioned how
Canadian media is basically controlled
by the government one thing one thing I
find very disturbing is that with the
United States media we do have media
which is controlled by private
corporations but honestly can you
imagine it acting all that differently
if it was controlled and regulated by
the government they continually cheer
for bigger government they insult people
and they smear them for calling for more
freedom and calling for the restrictions
the government imposes upon the average
person to end and when you look at the
situation in Canada like I mentioned
it's clear that our private media is
more sympathetic to their state media in
Canada and the views that they hold than
they are to the views of the actual
people of our country or theirs bro
there's no mask anymore it's funny when
the Mandate The Mask mandate is over no
I mean I mean the figurative mask that
that we we ever assumed the media was on
our side I'm done having that
conversation it's been 10 years anybody
who still thinks the media is telling
the truth is probably lying to you to be
completely honest like even regular
people when you ask them like the Press
rates abysmally low in terms of
credibility there was this funny poll
from a few years ago and it was like who
do you trust like how much trust do you
give these institutions and the Press
was on the bottom at like 17 when um
what's his name Glenn Greenwald got
booted out of The Intercept that was a
big like red light for me I that that
it's that structure of that that old
media thing doesn't work anymore you
can't be honest in that situation
because there's too many corporate
donors trying to get a hold of your you
and your money yeah yeah so like it's
it's not even that just that they're
biased to one side of the political
aisle they're beholden to corporate
interests a lot of these media outlets
and a lot of the time corporate in you
know obvious as we said before there's
this Unholy alliance between government
in America and big corporations and the
media is a part of that you have like an
institution like the Washington Post
that's owned by the sen the second
richest man in the world yeah and you
know obviously obviously their coverage
is going to not reflect the views of you
know people in Working Class People in
Ohio or working-class truckers uh
speaking out against these mandates you
know they support all these things you
know how I see it I'm like thinking
about the media and it reminds me of
those movie tropes where it's like
there's a wife and then her husband runs
up and she has a gun and he's like honey
it's me put down the gun and then all of
a sudden another like clone of her
husband runs the other side he's like no
no I'm your real husband and she's like
I don't know which one is real I don't
know what that Trope came from like the
original movie but it feels like there's
like a normie regular American sitting
on their couch and we run in and we're
like we're telling you the truth we're
challenging the lies and then you know
Brian Salter runs and he goes don't
listen to them we're we're the truth
they're telling you lies that's exactly
because I feel sorry for you no
um it's true and I think it's funny
because for years and years right after
Trump was elected that was elected The
Narrative was you know everything was
fine people trusted the media we had a
great relationship with the public and
then all DT came along and made him hate
us with all of his rhetoric about how
bad the media is he was like well no you
guys were already pretty terrible and
mostly politicians were willing to bend
the need you and then one came around
who wasn't and it opened your eyes to
how unpopular you are because the reason
most people are at the very least many
people are cheering for Donald Trump was
because you hated him and he hated you
and that meant that he was more on your
side than theirs
um and I just love to see their their
narrative crumble with each turn you're
sort of talking about how Canada is much
more authoritarian than the us but the
fact that the people of that country
have formed literally the largest Convoy
that we have ever been aware of in human
history to protest their government's
mandates is really incredible it's a
giant white pill there was a big Convoy
of uh diesel trucks about a thousand
years ago
yes of course no I I understand that I
understand I I understand it's a more
recent Phenomenon with the trucks but
also the largest con fight before this
was like five miles five miles and now
this is 45 miles Donald Trump
demonized and attacked the media because
people hate them yes because people got
access to the internet and it was like
the knowledge was beamed down to the
people and then all of a sudden they
were like hey wait a minute they're
lying to us about everything and then
Trump was like that's right Trump is a
symptom of not the creator of but of
course the media is now saying Donald
Trump he started all of this you know
2007 I was doing YouTube videos a lot
and I was getting real political I was
like we need to direct to the politician
now we have internet video we don't need
Secret Service Putin and Barack Obama
could get on a video chat and just talk
hang out and chill I could get on a
video chat with Barack no security
issues we just chat so we need that more
and I I was telling it to YouTube and
the people the YouTube um corporate
headquarters was listening and they were
yeah let's do YouTube debates so they
created this thing but then CNN get I
know on it and they're like no no we're
gonna do the CNN YouTube debates and
we're gonna water down all your
questions so I asked Barack like what's
up with the Federal Reserve why do we
have this system in place that's been
robbing creating interest and I was
talking about fractional reserve and um
they didn't air it they wouldn't hear
that they air all these softball
questions so CNN was the second guy and
he's like no I'm your husband Ian how
what was his response to that uh you
know Barack yeah he didn't hear it oh he
didn't even hear it okay so you're
saying CNN didn't give him the question
I thought you had an opportunity to
digitally ask the questions remember
later remember they did those town halls
and all of the people in town hall
turned out to be Democrat operatives
yeah
or like activists or whatever and I I
mean who's rigged man and who's
surprised by it even the presidential
debates when they actually have their
quote unquote opposition across from
them it's just a press conference anyway
the person throws their slogans out
there and then their opponent throws
their slogans out there yeah but did you
hear Republicans are now gonna boycott
the uh the commission on debates debates
so there's probably not going to be a
debate unless the Democrats come to them
for a debate this idea of odd debate
also bothers me now we're at a place
where you can pop on Skype or whatever
and video chat every Monday through
Friday it from 6 p.m to 7 P.M with you
whoever you want and everyone can watch
come on 21st century yeah like shows
like this one like have really really
changed the game and like you know we
were you know we were going to talk
about Joe Roe we were going to talk
about Joe Rogan soon it's like you know
shows like your shows like Rogan shows
like Tucker Carlsons that draw all of
these eyeballs because they don't bend
to institutional powers in corporate
media are a threat to those are a threat
and obviously you've been targeted with
cancel culture and obviously the cancel
culture Knives have come down with Joe
for Joe Rogan and Tucker Carlson the
only reason for it is because instead of
telling the truth these institutional
Powers have now chosen that they're just
gonna they're gonna pressure
corporations to censor their opposition
do you notice a lot of corporate
interference when you're working with
like just candidacy and like positioning
your candidates on social media and
stuff do you feel like pushback from
corporations while you're doing it you
have to navigate through that kind of
thing well I mean no because we wouldn't
really work with anybody who is so
beholden to corporate powers like we
don't obviously we're a company of seven
people and we would never we would never
do that and you know what's what's what
really what really sucks is that like
there are a lot of members of Congress
that I'm sure most Republicans probably
like and respect a lot who take a lot of
money from Big Tech and take a lot of
money from and so they and part of the
reason I think he's asking if with the
candidates you work with are they being
censored and shut down oh yeah yeah we
have to face that all the time and it's
it's on so one of the one of the clients
that we work with is American principles
project shout out to Terry Schilling and
John schweppe and before we worked with
them this happened during the last
election cycle but they they had their
Facebook demonetized because they ran an
ad in Michigan that opposed biological
men and women's sports and the way
Facebook works is in order to get a fact
check a fact Checker actually has to
write a fact check of your thing so some
and obviously the fact Checkers are
complete Liars like these political
factors in the world but so a fact
Checker wrote a fact check on on an ad
that opposed biological men and women
sports and they got their Facebook
account to monetize for that and so it's
stuff like that that happens all the
time it's it's it's remarkable that uh I
mean it's it we're in an amalgam of all
these different dystopian novels it's
like all of these writers could see a
piece but not the whole because you know
in this instance it's very uh
the fact Checkers are keeping us from
knowing things the major corporations
are you know stifling free enterprise
it's like it's like the inversion of
everything Wars peace you know et cetera
et cetera no yeah that's absolutely true
they want to be able to dictate the
public narrative and they and you know
when somebody when there's threats out
there that are drawing all the eyeballs
away from them they get scared and
because they're weak and pathetic they
go straight for Century censorship let's
let's carry on we we do have a lot to
talk about with the with the great
haunting what's going to be happening in
the U.S but let's let's carry this
conversation forward talking about
what's going on with Joe Rogan we have
this story from timcast.com Rumble
publicly offers Joe Rogan 100 million
dollars for a four-year censorship free
contract Rumble posted Hey Joe Rogan we
are ready to fight alongside you saying
how about you bring all of your shows to
rumble both old and new with no
censorship for 100 million bucks over
four years this is our chance to save
the world and yes this is totally legit
based on the reporting about rumble's uh
special purpose acquisition company 2.1
billion dollar evaluation and
potentially 400 million dollars in
liquid cash to spend I think they could
do this but I don't see why Joe Rogan
would do this this because it would be
basically him saying that he wants to
say the n-word that's that's that's the
issue right now so it's like not a good
time to offer Joe Rogan 100 million
dollars for censorship free contracts
because the issue at hand is that Joe
himself according to the Spotify CEO is
the one who took down all of the
episodes last Friday
but that apology video man that Joe put
out was a mistake it's making everything
worse and perhaps the issue is
when people say Joe has Fu money maybe
it means Fu to everybody and a lot of
people who are libertarian Freedom
loving uh you know who want honesty
Integrity assume Joe is on their side
when in reality Joe is just Joe and just
is an honest guy you know what I mean
yeah he's doing his own thing and
doesn't necessarily have a particular
ideology sort of what you're saying like
like he's like obviously I am offended
by the lies of the mainstream press yeah
and I'll call them out and I stand for
that Joe is offended they lied about him
and lie often but isn't interested in
getting involved in a fight to change
the future of media you know what I mean
yeah I think it's true yeah he's not a
hero like don't don't put this guy on a
pedestal he's just a dude doing his life
man which also goes to show like how
just ridiculous the attacks against
Tamar because his like what is his show
their unfiltered conversations for about
three hours at a time with people of all
different opinions political Persuasions
it's not even all political and so the
fact that you know big institutional
powers find this guy a thread who just
has unfiltered conversations with people
yeah well one thing lefties do and I'm
not exactly sure how if this has been
the case with The Joe Rogan Experience
but I would be very surprised if it
wasn't because it's something you've
dealt with it's something that virtually
every large political show that I'm
aware of or has spoken about this uh has
dealt with but left-wing people will
refuse to do a podcast if it's hosted
too many right wing people and so then
you only have people who are moderate or
on the right doing the podcast no
lefties do it then lefties go oh my gosh
why aren't we being represented why can
our views get out there it's not it's
it's you're you're close it's not that
it's too many right-wing people it's too
many it's that the host has an opinion
contrary to this yes all right fair
enough and so they'll go I'm not going
to go on this podcast and so I'm I am
sure and again I can't say for certain I
don't know I don't speak for Joe Rogan
but I'm sure that there's a lot of
left-wing people who absolutely could do
The Joe Rogan Experience and let the
audience know what their opinions are
but they see Joe Rogan is a non-person
he's an evil bigot so why even engage
with him or his audience Kyle Kolinski
said that in his episode Joe never used
a slur but
he was very critical of Saudi Arabia and
Spotify has just opened up their Market
to Saudi Arabia some people said that
Joe mentioned a song lyric with a slur
in it I don't know you know uh Kyle
kolinsky said there was no slur in it we
also have these tweets from Adam kokash
where he said Joe basically told him
Spotify is not allowing him on the show
and that they took down his show because
they had too much misinformation in it
that sounds to me like
that does not sound true to be
completely honest like I don't see Joe
Rogan as the kind of guy to like call
somebody up and be like dude I'm so
sorry I took your episode down it's
because it was misinformation like those
are words that Joe doesn't or probably
won't use
so maybe the real issue is that Joe
did talk to Adam kokesh and said
something like look man Spotify doesn't
want you know these kind of shows and
there were issues with like the facts
that things that were being said they
weren't true so that you know they
didn't want it on their platform and
then Adam frames it as such like
misinformation uses those words right
exactly but as I say if that if that
statement from Adam is true
then yeah this is crazy this is
seriously crazy Joe outright being like
Spotify is pulling the strings yeah I
mean it's very much he said he said
situation we don't know Joe didn't say
anything yeah well exactly so we have
one person leveling an accusation and we
have to assume innocence until there's
proof of guilt we have to remain
agnostic on this but I would also say
that well yeah that doesn't sound like
something Joe Rogan would do to me I
don't know him uh as a person and he's
also not the kind of person I would have
figured as a public apology kind of guy
either so who knows I think he views
this show his show as like a little side
project and he wants it in a box just
like wrapped up and not stressing his
life out I saw him on Instagram he's
like this is how I'm dealing with all
the BS and it's like they light a
gorilla piece of gorilla ice cream on
fire and they're like and I'm on
mushrooms was part of it I was like yeah
dude he just wants to live man if it
gets too much of a hassle then it's too
much of a hassle you move on to
something else so I think what we see
from all of this is that
people shouldn't assume Joe Rogan is a
warrior like you said like fighting on
your side in the culture War he's a guy
who has conversations you happen to
agree with him on a decent amount of
those opinions that's about it yeah
or back you up unless he really believes
it sorry Sheamus yeah literally people
he's platformed he did literally save us
with uh with uh you know our medicine
he's just such a kind person man if you
watch his Fear Factor stuff in the early
days he's got this like
um dislike uh innate ability to motivate
and and give courage
it's just such a kind like a gentle
gorilla yeah
okay was the circling back though to I I
just want to reaffirm that yeah I mean
anything anything anyone has said that
he has said or done behind closed doors
like that we don't have any confirmation
on with respect to that situation you
have to like sort of stay on the side of
we don't know and we can't jump to
inclusions about it I want to say you
know because I want to make sure this is
in every time I bring up a video about
Joe that he's helped me out tremendously
having me on his show helped my career
tremendously uh having me on with CEO of
Jack CEO of Twitter Jack Dorsey was just
insane for me at the time so I'm like
dude I'm just some dude on YouTube with
like a hundred thousand Subs like why am
I sitting in front of the CEO of this
major biggest you know one of the
biggest companies in the world and so
Joe had me on and he said that you know
I thought he thought I was a smart guy
and I held my own he appreciated it he
opted out with our medical issues so I
think he's genuinely just like a really
good dude and I think I don't think he
ever expected to be in this position I
think he even said that he just wanted
to hang out and talk with his friends
and all of a sudden he had this Big Show
and it's crazy easy and he just wants to
chill but I will say
I think this is the the the it's it's
it's the it's it's all downhill from
here well the rumble thing I like I like
that Chris did this Chris pavlovski
because this is a big it's a it's a big
statement it's it's legitimate he will
pay Joe 100 million if he does it but
it's also tells Spotify if you mess with
Joe too much there's a exit ramp for
this dude so don't mess with this guy
because the world loves him I think I
think it's all downhill from here in
terms of what happened to The Joe Rogan
Experience as as Joe stated right when
he made this this video compilation of
him saying the n words really old it was
resurfaced by a Super PAC group or
something like that
his his position is my understanding
first of all he's never used the slur he
said the solar there's a big difference
citing the name of certain you know
comedy specials referencing the word
itself
but he recently came out and said
there are a lot of people that think
there's no context in which a white
person can say this word and I agree
with that now and I haven't said it for
years that's the change in Joe where
he's like okay I'll take this stuff down
but that is a very very important change
to reference
I think I'll say it this way there is no
context in which you will not face
severe repercussions for saying the word
descriptively the n-word right and it
becomes very difficult then when you
want to reference the names of
documentaries because there's there's
um different forms of what we would call
the n-word and this is already a very
difficult conversation to have because
it's hard for me to actually tell you
what the words are because if we say it
YouTube will take the show down outright
this is why I think we're we're at a
very we're having a very serious problem
in our public discourse there is no
reason why a smart honest individual
can't describe a word in fact there are
words that sound like the n-word you
can't say either a guy got cancer he's
not like Fox News and he used the word I
can't say that meant shrewd and they
attacked him for it it is absolutely
insane that you have an executive at
Netflix was telling people here's a list
of offensive words that should not be
aired on on our programs and he got
fired for telling people the word not to
say
this is psychotic when Joe says you know
after a few years I realized yes you're
right we should not be able to describe
this word
I completely disagree but it shows you
the cultural defeat because that
literally makes no sense none whatsoever
while I will absolutely acknowledge
we absolutely we we of course will never
reference there's I think six five or
six words we're talking about in a
members only podcast that start with the
letter N but are not the same word that
you can't say for a variety of reasons
one of them I'm willing to actually say
it's Nazi
by saying that YouTube has already
probably struck the channel we're
probably downranked demonetized all of
that stuff because YouTube doesn't think
that content is appropriate for
advertisers so you get hurt by it
there's other words that are reference
in documentaries that are not the
typical n-word but still are considered
offensive by today's standards I can't
describe that word to you or explain to
you what it is it makes it impossible to
explain to people what's going on at all
for Joe to come out and be like I agree
I agree there's no context I'm like
that's hardcore bending the knee to an
extreme degree here's what I would say
there are certain contexts where you
need to describe what words people
shouldn't be using in derogatory context
we're not allowed to say those words
because the Machine by which we have
this show on will ban us
on in the members only segment we've had
this conversation before and we still
refrain from using certain words but we
still get smeared for it anyway trying
to explain to people we simply want them
to understand context you're not allowed
I think that's a fair way to put it Joe
actually just sided with the left's
perspective that you shouldn't be
allowed to describe words yeah I was
thinking like what if your kid comes to
you and it's like Daddy why why is this
word so bad and acid says the word and
you're like I can't talk about it like
could you imagine not being able to
communicate with your child and explain
why things are the way they are I'm not
living that life well one thing I found
really funny about this story is after
they canceled Joe Rogan or tried to
cancel him over this uh video resurfaced
to use that lovely euphemism by the way
that means they dug it up somebody went
looking for it and found it but uh
footage also resurfaced of Joe Biden
saying the n-word and we're being told
that we have to look at that
contextually but not when Joe Rogan used
it well here's the thing none of them
actually care like yeah I'm pretty sure
most rational people don't live under
this perspective that anyone who's ever
said that word no matter the context
should be canceled to platformed Etc
they want to they want to the platform
Joe Rogan and they're going to do
anything to do it they have they're
going to dig up anything they're gonna
they'll go and through any great length
to cancel his show because it's a threat
to the institutional power of the
establishment many people pointed out
sexism is next they're gonna pull up the
things he said about women then you're
going to have homophobia then you're
gonna have transphobia these videos all
exist already the the video of Joe and
the Planet of the Apes story has been
around for years it's a very very old
video Joe apologizing in my opinion is
him basically giving up
like like he doesn't that's what I'm
saying he doesn't want to fight I'm not
saying he has to fight I'm not saying I
just it's I'm mad at him for not wanting
to fight I'm saying like he said man
he's just wanted to hang out with his
friends and talk about stuff and how he
is in this position
I shouldn't maybe giving up is is
inappropriate because it implies he
wanted this fight in the first place I
think Joe stood up for himself on many
occasions like when he challenged Sanjay
Gupta on CNN this is clearly a fight
he's not willing to stand up for himself
on I think he's deflected it he's a jiu
jitsu Master that's one way to call it
Blackness he's also black belt and Jiu
Jitsu got everybody yeah for many Bravo
I saw a video of it's on YouTube um of
him giving him the belt it's real
emotional but he's also a mental Jujitsu
artist he knows how to maneuver energy
so that it doesn't get in his way
I appreciate that about Joe but do you
do you feel that's really what he's done
in this situation it's kind of like in
here it's what he is kind of he's very
very not passive but able to pass
through things I'm I literally don't
understand his his thinking on this one
at all yeah these people who don't watch
his show they they don't like him
they're never going to like him
apologizing will do nothing and by
apologizing what's happening now is all
of these videos are popping up of people
being like whoa Joe Rogan admitted it he
admitted to everything he said he's
admitted he's got a great detail about
it and he said he thought it was
entertaining like dude
the people who like you don't know don't
care they've seen your show already
they've watched your show from the
beginning they get it people who don't
like you they're never gonna like you
you guys are so what is the point I want
to point this out there is something
inherently absurd
with the idea of apologizing to a group
of people who are literally saying that
context doesn't matter because that
means the context of your apology
doesn't matter all they see is you
bending the knee and then they want more
this is some oh are you gonna say
something okay you can go first well
working at mines I I co you know worked
with mines for a long time co-founder of
the company with Bill Bill ottman the
CEO and he kept telling me it was like
2013 14 15 16 he was like context
matters and I I was like yeah I know
Bill but like and he's like contact like
talking about how to administrate the
website context matters a robot cannot
take a piece of text out it makes no
sense it can but it makes no sense
ethically or constructively you know
morally to do that so context but how do
you teach a a computer system about
context well here's the here's the thing
like social media is is not context
doesn't exist on Twitter or on the
Internet or anything like this like the
goal of people on these platforms is
just to beat you until you submit to
them and so like if so if you're you
know if you're anybody who gets caught
in one of these situations like you
can't bend the knee like because they
won't care they're never gonna stop like
you know Glenn Young and the governor of
Virginia did something like this over
the weekend where he apologized for a
tweet where he his campaign account made
fun of this high school kid who tweeted
a viral lie about him but like obviously
they didn't obviously they didn't they
were like oh this isn't a real apology
like you can't bend the need of these
people at all because they all they want
is your career to be destroyed yeah and
so you have to stand up to them and even
if it is an authentic apology even if
they accept that it's an authentic
apology this is not a group of people
that believes in forgiveness or
Redemption you are always the person who
did that and they will always smear you
with it and I do believe this is a great
conversation the we talked about this
before the show using a slur at someone
and talking about a word are different
different environments different
meanings and so that sort of seems to
have been lost any word in the flow of
text yeah yeah uh so I I truly believe
that talking about words that have been
used as racist slurs in the past is very
important for a species to evolve and
move past it and and make it part of us
and then like old words that used to be
really offensive we don't they're not
offensive anymore a lot of those words
yeah that's just the nature of human
communication yeah no exactly I mean so
so if um you know a child uses a swear
word they drop the F-bomb and then Dad
gets home from work and mom goes Johnny
said what the f and she drops the the
word there's a world of difference
between that and her husband coming home
from work and she looks at him and she
says Fu like she's saying the F word in
both contexts or in both situations but
the context is extremely different in
one situation she is actually using it
to hurt someone and in the other
situation she's using it to either
illustrate a point or to describe what
someone else has said
so necessary and I want to bring that
back to social media somehow to culture
to Common culture
like is like the hot tip of the the
spear here man but I'm I you know this
is a conversation that's necessary yeah
but like when you're on the internet
though it's like oh you said this word
you shouldn't have a thing anymore like
these things don't exist on Twitter it's
not it's not a place where nuances the
news outlets are all saying video of Joe
using exactly the n-word and so even if
you even if you want to argue that
there's a better euphemism to use for
the word when describing it it's clear
that there is a very large difference
between using it and referencing yeah if
you had like a bunch of blocks of
letters that said the word and then you
took a sledgehammer and smashed them
you'd be using the word
but in like an alliterative artistic
manner we know the media falsely frames
things we know that all they do they'll
they'll they'll twist whatever you did
in any way possible to to push the
narrative they want I'll tell you what I
think
I think Joe's deal with Spotify people I
see people chatting and they're like
they're in the chat saying you know he's
probably got an NDA he's probably got
morality Clauses about what he can and
can't do about controversies and Spotify
probably told him to apologize or
whatever and he can't talk about it I
don't know I think uh I think Joe's
probably got equity and I I think he got
shares of Spotify
when you think about the biggest podcast
in the world what's the real incentive
for going exclusive there have been many
outlets many many tech companies who
have asked me and they're like you know
how about an equity deal and I'm just
like not interested I literally don't
care about that but I understand why
someone would say it's a good deal I
mean think about it the Wall Street
Journal reports that Joe Rogan gets 100
million dollars they say it's a
multi-year contract everyone assumes
this always means cash
it doesn't so my contract with Fusion
which was the ABC News Univision joint
venture was valued at like three to five
million dollars but direct compensation
was only like 700. the rest of the stuff
was like discretionary budget Staffing
hiring but it was a big contract so if
you're trying to do a big pitch you can
be like Spotify you know you could be
like you know Disney nabs up Tim pool
with a five million dollar contract or
something like that it sounds like I'm
getting all this money I'm not getting
in my opinion
I don't know exactly what the you know
the specifics of Joe's deal uh with
Spotify was but I'd imagine they
probably came to him and said x amount
of cash x amount of shares and maybe
like a bonus or something like that I
would imagine in a boat for Jamie like
so so actually so so uh Ian you're
having worked with Minds yeah like
you've worked a lot of companies they
offer Equity as incentives to sign on
people and stuff yeah a lot of times
what you do is you vest the equity
meaning that you sign a contract saying
I'm going to work here for this amount
of time five years and every year I'll
earn a portion of my percentage of
equity that I will be earning in total
so for me it was one percent of the Mine
stock uh every year I would get like
point three percent or 0.2 and as long
as I stayed at the company I would keep
accruing it and if I left it anytime I'd
have what I had so let's say that 100
million dollar deal for Rogan was
outright because you know he still has
he sells commercials on the show right
yes on Spotify he does like yeah yeah
VOD is that what it's called he says
them directly direct direct ad sales so
I'd imagine Spotify would have nothing
to do with that it's a licensing deal
right so let's say the Spotify went to
him and said
it's a multi-year contract and we'll
give you 100 million dollars in in
equity right now
right now as soon as he signs that deal
the stock jumped by what like 20 yeah so
I don't know exactly what the specifics
of their deal was but I would imagine a
good reason why Joe probably came out
and apologized
he's got equity in the company
interesting yeah it has nothing to do
with cancel culture has nothing to do
it's just literally like how can I you
know make sure this isn't going bad for
everybody who's you know investing in
this company I think it's multi-layered
obviously obviously I think Joe
obviously doesn't like the fact that
that video exists I think he's very I
think he's genuine and sincere when he
was like man I watch that video and I'm
like I cringe watching it you know I you
know I wish I didn't say these things
and some of these things were crude and
Crest I think he's genuine but I think
you know part of the motivation is
you know gotta gotta protect his
business gotta protect his assets and I
don't I think everyone just assumes
I've seen a lot of people on the left
pointing this out people on the right
just assume Joe Rogan is on their side
in this great culture War battle and he
just happens to agree with him a lot of
things but Joe Rogan is just a comedian
and Entertainer who talks about stuff he
cares about don't expect him to jump in
the line of fire for you but at the same
time like defending Free Speech
defending you know
unfilled the unfiltered conversations
that he has I think it's important for
our discourse and I think it's even more
important is that he he gives another
side of the story that very very
powerful institutions want to censor and
so the reason you know I I think the
reason like most people admire Joe Rogan
and defend Joe Rogan people on the right
I would say is for those reasons because
like you know people we believe in free
speech we believe that it's important to
talk about things and not and that sen
and that censorship is for weak people
and so like in terms when you just
thinking in terms of defending this idea
of free speech without censorship I
think that's why the people on the right
defend him in the way that they've been
doing well here's here's the next big
move we got the story from CNBC Spotify
CEO apologizes to staff for Joe Rogan
controversy as episodes get removed the
CEO said that it was Joe who pulled the
episodes and they've gone on to announce
that they will be investing where is
this thing 100 million dollars the CEO
of Spotify said they will invest a
hundred million dollars for the
licensing development and marketing of
music and audio content from
historically marginalized groups I don't
know exactly what that means but I can
tell you this if Spotify takes 200
million dollars and gives 100 to Joe
Rogan and a hundred to historically
marginalized groups on the surface I
could care less more speech is better
more speech is good the problem is we're
not getting more speech Joe Rogan is
conceding and apologizing and bending
the knee and changing his positions and
the woke left is getting a massive
influx of cash so this is not more
speech it's the same old establishment
talking points and the one show there's
a reason why it's so big Joe Rogan's
show the the one the one show with a big
enough footprint that actually moved the
needle that discusses anti-establishment
talking points is bending the knee even
if it's only a little bit so we are not
gaining in this a lot of people pointed
out when Joe said
I'll try my hardest to have you know if
I have one person that's controversial
I'll have another expert following him
it's like oh okay so the establishment
mainstream media which controls billions
of views per month that everyone's
already seen and the one guy the one
time gets a chance to speak out like Dr
Robert Malone on this audience you're
gonna give the establishment the
rebuttal when they already own the
entire narrative I think the goods not a
win the tactic is to have them on
together Sanjay and Malone and then the
truth will come out well Rogan can be
the hold the microphone some people have
said you know
every all these all these you know
people are absolutely right Joe should
not be platforming misinformation Dr
fauci should go on his show for three
hours and explain everything in detail
wouldn't that be wonderful and then and
then in six months that'll be
misinformation it'll have to take it
down well that's you know that's the
thing that's what Joe literally said in
the first video he made that a lot of
the stuff that Dr uh Malone and and
McCullough talked about
a year ago would get you banned for so
he's not going to stop then what happens
is these activists resurface a really
old video a compilation of out of
context clips
and Joe said he felt bad about me
apologized for it the issue is
there's two fundamentally Different
World Views Joe is clearly of the world
view that we occupy that there are
certain contexts where describing things
is okay
the other worldview claims that Joe used
the slur simply by uttering its word in
descriptive context Joe does not occupy
that worldview although he's claiming
now he understands it and agrees with
them does he really agree with him or is
he scared of them because I'll be
completely honest
I completely will openly admit I
recognize there are conversations you
can't have you will get banned out right
Joe is coming out and saying basil that
same thing that's why I'm kind of like
oh you know I kind of get it I guess I
get it I use mean humor when I was a kid
it was kind of a part of our friend
group and we would call each other
really abusive names and like race be
racist and all this gross stuff and then
I learned somewhere in college I went to
theater school and it was very liberal
homosexuality was present and I learned
like
you can't just make fun of people
because of the way they are and I
stopped doing it and man has my life
become better I I don't have crap for
most part anything like I haven't done
the racist the the hateful not that it's
hateful comedy but the I haven't made
people have thought of my jokes since
since I was 2001 or something edgy
comedy was all the Rave in the 90s and
2000s and now it's just comedy is
forbidden man well I mean it's
interesting too because especially in
the late 90s early 2000s all of the edgy
comedy was being done by left-wing
people who are trying to promote a
left-wing message and on some level I
think that's why they were so successful
in the culture War at that time
I think there's a simple solution to all
of this for one
look Joe's got a really Big Show and
that's why this news is getting so much
attention everyone is talking about it
it's getting bigger Joe's apology video
made the story substantially larger his
second apology made it even larger it's
not going to go away unless or until you
know uh the story is not going to stop
until Joe's show is gone for whatever
reason either pulled off or he quits
because you know they want the political
establishment they want him gone before
the midterms they can't have him
propping you know these voices or
anything like that
but I think
none of this in the end is is really
going to matter you know what matters
infrastructure infrastructure one of the
one of the challenges we face is that we
use YouTube for one of our you know key
pieces of infrastructure the live
portion of the show a lot of people have
pointed out that we should use Rumble
it's true the issue is Rumble is a
fraction of a fraction of a fraction of
the audience that YouTube has and while
a lot of people have said so what just
do Rumble anyway I don't think people
realize that I would say maybe like 70
percent of the people who watch this
show are not super politically active
people they don't know what Rumble is
they won't watch Rumble they'll just be
confused one day as to why this show is
gone that's all they'll know it's gone
and I think it's against terms of
service of YouTube if we run like an ad
from eight to ten on YouTube that says
come to the rumble stream like they
don't you can't do it's against terms of
service to tell people there's there's
clever things people do where they'll
they'll stream for a minimum amount of
time and then announce they're doing a
stream somewhere else but if you like
YouTube has a rule that if you announce
you're streaming somewhere else and then
leave it's a bannable offense yeah
outright ban your whole Channel also you
have to think about why YouTube and
Google are implementing a lot of these
different censorship censorship
strategies and the reason is because
left-wing activists complain to them and
say things like you're allowing this
person on this platform and often
they'll say you're allowing people to be
radicalized by this specific person on
this platform someone who's come to
YouTube for reasons that are totally
non-political will see a temple video or
a freedom Tunes video or a Crowder video
and they will get sucked on this deep
dark rabbit hole what the person is
really saying is that other ideas are
being given a voice on this platform and
I don't like that for our response to be
you know what then we're just going to
get off their platform and give them
exactly what they want is in some ways
for us to admit to feed yeah it's like
there's a big Battlefield and you know
the ranks are being flattened so a yell
Retreat let's go seed the battlefield
it's in and it's true I mean eventually
yeah YouTube could ban each and every
one of our channels and I think it's
important to have a contingency plan uh
for if and when that happens but the
fact that the left wing is out there
saying they're on YouTube and that's bad
makes me very much want to stay on
YouTube because I want to do the things
that the left thinks are terrible so
there's a couple things to say one this
is why we have timcast.com so we can
host you know conversations in our
quote-unquote Speak Easy but the other
thing I'll say is
if someone is here's what I tell people
they're like hey I want to get started
doing a podcast or whatever I'm like do
it on Rumble don't start on YouTube
Rumble has for new channels in my
opinion an opportunity for growing an
audience faster than YouTube does and an
opportunity for a style of content that
is greatly missing in the market
I started making YouTube videos as
content and censorship was getting worse
and worse and worse here we are with it
with a big platform and a lot of people
who watch so I think it's important to
maintain but we do Post everything to
rumble as well and for timcast.com we
use Rumble infrastructure if you're
starting a new channel look at Dan
bongino Dan bongino had 2 million
subscribers on Rumble and only like 700
or 800 000 on YouTube so for if you're
starting a new channel I would say start
it on Rumble and we've talked about this
too if you want to do comedy you can
really do comedy on Rumble the links can
be shared then ultimately what it comes
down to is it's not about Joe it's not
about any individual it's about
infrastructure it's about the ability of
individuals to freely speak without him
without having to be uh to worry about
being banned so in the event we ever did
get banned oh yeah we'd immediately be
on you know Rumble most likely
but uh you know they're not perfect
either we'd still operate much the same
way and you know we probably just carry
on but there'll be a lot of people who
would be genuinely confused to what
happened to the show they you know
YouTube will probably lose some
viewership but man I gotta tell you
when we are sick or we have a
cancellation and so the show doesn't
happen we can post about why doesn't
happen everywhere and we still get
emails from people saying like where's
the show I even get Facebook messages
from family like where's the show and
I'm like man we literally post it on
Twitter on Instagram on YouTube like we
post it all over the place and people
don't see it they just turn on the TV
date turn it off at 10. so a lot of
people tell me they turn on their TV
open the YouTube app and then watch the
show live on their TVs and we've also
seen a whole bunch of images that was
really funny I think Luke it was Luke he
was browsing Amazon you remember this
yeah yeah he was browsing Amazon looking
at TVs to buy and one of the TVs had a
product description like photos and the
photo was us on the TV it was really
really funny So Meta so so anyway look
the point is we're we're beholden to
YouTube for a lot of ways but I like to
imagine that we have we have extended
some kind of bridge from YouTube to
rumble to to bit shoot to gab to mines
to any other of his other platforms
where people can still communicate and
share so my advice is anyone starting
new channels Rumble is a your
opportunity I'm very interested in
integrating minds and Rumble it's it's
on the talking table right now I've been
hanging out with Chris and Bill and I'm
like obsessed with this I want to put it
together I want to bring Andrew come on
in buddy I know over there gab I see you
uh I love you Andrew I think integrating
gab mines and uh Rumble and library is
so key and right there in front of us
very excited that's like one of the
things we do is we like you know the
candidates that we work with and a lot
of the uh you know organizations we work
with are you know the big Tech
censorship's a very important issue to
them and so like when we work with the
candidate we want to steer like we want
to steer them towards you know when we
get this new GOP majority we actually
have to do something change laws in
Congress that can prevent big Tech from
sense from politically motive from doing
politically motivated censorship and you
know because of the lobbying budgets
they have that's why it's never been
done because a lot of you know
unfortunately it's a lot of Republicans
who take money from these companies and
then laws are never changed and the
censorship continues is there a way to
get that money out of politics uh well
no no because we have citizens because
we have the citizens united case where
corporations are considered people and
they have free speech so you know there
are campaign Finance laws like the FEC
has like laws but you know there are
ways like there are ways around it just
as there are ways around you know
billion like rich people when they pay
their taxes
yeah so we have to repeal what was it
called uh citizens united that's the
name of the Supreme Court case but you
know it's a supreme court overturned
it's very tough to repeal that yeah it's
a it's a precedent basically allows
super Pacs to spend it comes from way
back in the 1800s a guy a really rich
guy wanted to run for president had all
this money he was like why can't I use
my own money on my own campaign I want
to take a train around the US and
they're like he's kind of making a good
point and that was the first step of
like hey rich guy gets to do a policy
it's a little easier
and so they start passing laws to kind
of Aid the wealthy after that
yeah but I mean what I think is that the
GOP has changed a lot on the issue of
big Tech and I think we're starting to
see them get a lot more serious you know
with with on that issue and I you know
when we get this new GOP majority in
this new midterm election that should be
that's that's an issue they need to
focus on yeah they talk about breaking
up big Tech I don't think you can break
up the corporation that's why I talk
about freeing the software code of big
social networks I wonder if it's too
fascist to order the government to but
it's kind of like breaking up a monopoly
well yeah I mean our antitrust law is
fascist
I don't think so they're like
anti-fascist
yeah yeah it depends on who you ask I
guess
look I think I think if you're like a
libert I mean I I would say most
Libertarians would be against that sort
of thing but I would say as you know as
somebody on the as a conservative as
somebody I distrust if you distrust you
know concentrated power in the
government you should also distrust
concentrated power in corporations and I
think one of the things people on the
right you know Miss today is that
government today is is not the only
threat to our Liberty corporations that
get too big can be just as big of a
threat and even more of a threat like
what would you say is a bigger threat to
your freedom today the government or
Google yeah I know exactly yeah
the military uh concerns me but a
corporation can hire private military
basically it can have armed security and
then if they want to flick a Switch and
Go psycho you're like well glad we have
a government to protect us
well let's talk about what's uh what's
coming next for the U.S right so outside
of media and big Tech and all that stuff
we still have some direct action we got
the story from Rolling Stone Republican
lawmaker basically begs anti-vax
truckers to blockade the Super Bowl
there's almost no chance of the blockade
happening but rep Wendy Rogers part of
the Law and Order GOP is basically
pining for it saying if truckers shut
down the Super Bowl it would it would
partially be payback for Colin
Kaepernick and the kneeling is that
begging is that practically begging yeah
it's it's this is the the nature of
media these days everything's hyperbole
I mean it is what it is but um I don't
know if there's actually going to be a
convoy to the Super Bowl other than I've
seen more than just Wendy Rogers
bringing up I've seen people on on
Twitter and other forums actually say it
would be a good idea and they'd want to
do it
there's also the the U.S Convoy that's
supposedly forming to go to DC as well
so Americans are absolutely getting on
board with this what if a convoy went
over to the Olympics I think the CCP
would do anything how would they even
get in it the bearing straight plus it's
like the Winter Olympics so it'd be like
driving up a mountain or something it's
still crazy to me that like after just a
year where China Unleashed a pandemic on
the world that killed millions of people
they've cracked down on on Hong Kong
they're they've committed a genocide and
the world responds by sending all of
their athletes there to compete in the
Olympics people are gloating and all
these athletes who are getting injured
and screwing up there's that one uh
chinese-american woman who uh uh she she
resent she what's what's the word she
abandoned are you talking about Eileen
goo the skier no no no no she she just
like slipped on her skis or whatever oh
you're talking about an injury okay no
I'm talking about that woman who fell uh
ice skating and uh she had renounced her
American citizenship to escape for China
instead of America wait what I didn't
see that yeah that happened yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
a chinese-american-born woman renounced
U.S citizenship to uh I think I have it
maybe because when you when you said
that I was thinking of uh here we go
yeah
falls again breaks down in tears the
Olympics people are making fun of her
because uh she gave up American
citizenship and now she's Fallen twice
and uh people in China are mocking her
and insulting her and laughing at her
yeah sad I mean I was thinking I was
thinking of the skier or the skier uh
who was born in America and grew up in
San Francisco her mom her mom was from
China and she competed for the U.S until
two years ago and she switched to China
and is now competing for China in the
Olympics is she the one who shattered
her leg
no I don't think so her name's her
name's Eileen goo you sure I believe so
something about a shattered leg I didn't
I mean I haven't watched like the
Olympics at all for obvious reasons so I
don't no no no
was she I don't know there's uh there
was two one there was I think she was
the one who lost one of her skis but
then just like slid it out and was
totally fine but there's another skier
who's doing slalom and she like slipped
out and then her legs spiraled and she
like fractured her tibia or whatever
what's the bone down there the tibia is
the toe Bones the figure is the finger I
know TMF that's all remember oh is it
yeah no what's what's femur is the Lydia
looks like she thinks the doctor femur
is like that biggest bone the biggest
bone he's at fibio yeah
the the bone between your knee and your
foot that one that's like the femur no
no the femur is your thighs between me
and your foot it's your biggest bone
yeah yeah
fibula yeah
I was way off but she like is the arm
she like spiraled it it was brutal the
tone yeah but that is that is a really
good point that uh oh it's the fibula
it's different than the fibia I guess
those are different people I it's I all
of these athletes who are agreeing to
this I'm just I'm sitting back with my
feet up while they're all complaining
about the conditions they have to go
through because apparently like
communist China is unpleasant who would
have known once all these athletes are
like it's so miserable here and I'm like
don't go dude I'm sorry people are like
but they've but they've worked so hard
their whole lives for the Olympics and
it's like so what there was that woman
who was a chess Grandmaster refused to
go to Iran because she wasn't going to
wear a hijab and I'm like that's awesome
yeah good for her she was like screw
that I ain't doing it and I'm like yes
start a YouTube channel play chess
online but these people chose what they
care more about it shows you it shows
what they care more about these people
who are willing to go to China to
compete all every single one of them
they care more about a piece of gold on
their neck than they do about
concentration camps about potential war
and conflict about what's going on in
Hong Kong I think it's gross like actors
with the Emmys and the Oscars want to
get that medal do anything same thing
bend down and stay quiet you get that
medal
yeah I mean I was an athlete growing up
so like I understand if you're someone
who's playing a sport your whole life
you know you dream of going to the
Olympics this is your chance like I get
it like I get it you know it's hard to
give that up it's just to make just to
make a political statement like I'm I'm
thinking like it like it's like put
yourself in their shoes like if you're
someone who's been training your entire
life in this sport the Olympics is your
dream it's hard like it's hard to give
that up I don't I don't so that's why I
don't like I don't really blame anyone
for doing this I Blame You Know America
for not standing up and saying no we're
not sending our people to China why is
it incumbent upon the government to stop
athletes as individuals well no not the
I'm not necessarily the government I'm
talking about like you know the
governing body of USA Athletics right if
if the USA came out and boycotted the
Olympics they'd be forcing all the
athletes like what the athletes could
just choose not to go yeah that's true
but like but but but like I said like
it's hard like it's really tough like if
you're if you're an athlete like that
like I understand that would that's a
that's the toughest decision to make I I
just as someone who played Sports my
whole life sure and I mean I agree that
it's a tough decision but also just
because it's the difficult decision
doesn't mean it isn't the right one
oftentimes it is I'm really confused I
don't think it's a difficult decision at
all like well when he's saying no I I
don't think it's a difficult decision
morally I think it's very
straightforward I think you don't go I
think what he's saying is that they have
to make a large personal sacrifice but
what I'm saying is even if you have to
make a large personal sacrifice to do
the right thing you should still do it
and I do blame them for not yeah it's
like how many how many uh like how many
people murdered in genocide is too much
for you as an Olympic Athlete you know
what I mean exactly because clearly
because clearly what's happening to the
uyghur Muslims what's happened to Hong
Kong what they're threatening over
Taiwan is that enough for any of these
people to be like yeah maybe I don't go
into a Beijing on this one didn't and
would it be funny if even a small
fraction of all the Olympic athletes
were like Hey we're not gonna We're Not
Gonna compete as individuals I just I'm
not gonna go to China and then China
would have to be like maybe we should
stop doing this to the uyghur Muslims
because we're losing out on the Olympics
what uh Jesse Owen ones I'm thinking of
1936 Berlin Olympics Nazi Germany he
went and performed black guy and like it
was like a big deal in Nazi Germany and
he won four gold medals yeah and he made
a global statement and that was a big
deal so there's a chance for people to
go to China and be like yo down with
Communism but Nancy Pelosi's like please
don't do that because they're crazy over
there I don't I don't I don't like the
whole go and protest at the event thing
you know I said it before I'm just like
maybe sporting should just be sporting
and because they they're banning like
they announced they banned black lives
matter at these events and I'm like yeah
well you know maybe if people want to
just go and compete and it doesn't have
to be political all the time every
single time however
I think it's also fair to then be like
you don't got a protest there but you
also don't have to go there you know the
Olympics have always been very neutral
even way back to Athens in the original
Olympics it was a it was a time for all
these different Athenian uh or all these
different Greek Nations to come together
even if they were at war with each other
they agreed that they would let the
athletes pass through their territory
even if countries they were at war with
to go to the Olympics because it was so
fun it was just like that's the human
you know that we play you know what do
you guys so what do you guys think of
the World Cup so we have the World Cup
coming up too in November and it's in
Qatar and apparently and they're
building and and so how many corpses are
in the stadium in that building so so
they had to move it so usually it's in
the summer but they moved it to November
because of how hot it gets there in the
summer and apparently like the reports
that they're using like slave labor to
build oh yeah of course of course for a
long time they're they're uh reports I I
could be wrong about this or fetching me
it's been a long time since I read about
this but like uh corpses in the rubble
as they're building it's just like up
somebody died well Barry over them it's
crazy I mean it just shows how like
corrupt you know the international
governing bodies of the Olympics and of
the of FIFA are that is that they give
like these these these countries somehow
got the chance to host this you got to
understand how people are how people are
is that they've spent their whole life
working towards a goal there is nothing
that will stand in their way for these
18 19 year old Olympic athletes who are
skiing or snowboarding they're like yo
look I know that China has these weaker
Muslims these win women being raped by
by Han Chinese men and force impregnated
I know they're doing forced abortions
and sterilization but I want
to kill in those camps right is that
what they're saying I think these people
are disgusting I think it's a very sad
reality and it's been difficult to see
that in many cases people only care
about morality in so far as their
reputation requires it and so we're on a
we're at a place where I imagine most
people would spend more time criticizing
atrocities of the past like Nazi Germany
or transatlantic slavery than they would
criticizing actual atrocities in the
world that people won't Pat them on the
back so much for addressing yeah there's
no sacrifice complaining about the past
exactly and and so I mean
again is there a statistical analysis
done in the snow but based on the
conversations I've had particularly with
left-leaning people I think there is
currently a lot more criticism going on
about Nazi Germany which ended in the
1900s right late 40s then there is
criticism of communist China which is
actually engaged in genocide right now
did you guys see the story about
Savannah Guthrie China using uyghur
athlete and Olympic ceremony and in your
face responds to the list this moment is
quite provocative it's a statement from
the Chinese president Xi Jinping
dude we are we are heading towards a
future where there is Chinese Communist
authoritarianism you mentioned there was
already one athlete who defective I
guess apparently more than one who's
defected from the United States to go
perform for China LeBron James may as
well go do it he's he's defended China
you've got Mark Cuban and apparently
Elon Musk is using social media what is
it weibo or whatever oh okay weibo I
don't know we I can't remember who we
had on the show they were talking about
how Elon Musk will say all these great
freedom things on Twitter but then he's
also on Chinese social media praising
China yeah we talked about ours did you
see this video got taken down by Twitter
too the original account that oh yeah
look at that we did it got taken down
it's been disabled in response to a
report by the copyright and so so the
copyright owners that NBC in this case
apparently yeah like to getting a video
of one of their reporters the stories
that have come out of China over what's
happening to the uyghur Muslims I hope
you guys realize it is it's on par with
like the some of the worst atrocities
we've ever heard of in the history of
mankind like forced abortions like
taking women and holding them down and
forced abortions for sterilization
bringing men in to rape these women
these these stories some of the the
images and the videos that have that
have come out are some of the most
nightmarish and grotesque things we've
ever seen and and and and Disney is
producing films in these regions and
apparently none of it matters none of it
matters to any one of these big
corporations none of it matters that's
right money money gotta get paid yeah I
mean I think a big difference between
you know atrocities between China and
you know authoritarian countries in the
past that have committed atrocities is
that China like we've never seen the
amount of financial interests that China
has with the with the West like it's in
compared terrible to like the Soviet
Union or any of any of these other
countries like the like the influence
China has over the biggest corporations
in the world the biggest corporations in
America who are just drunk on their
Chinese dollars like that's that's the
difference that's why that's why that's
why it's it's all about money earlier
you mentioned um that with the way
you're saying it was that you said the
Chinese unleashed the the virus on the
world I want I want to create some
Nuance because I think it's more that
there was a technocratic scientist group
of scientists that did it well at least
I guess covered up what may have been a
better but the poor people of China are
like suffering I mean I I don't know I
don't know I'm not there and I'm not a
Chinese but it looks like that they're
underneath this substrat or they're the
sub of the substrate I don't know
mechanical authoritarianism or something
I mean I would I would somewhat agree
with that but what do you think they say
about us I don't know probably similar
things they criticize our censorship on
social media they criticize our police
they it was really interesting there's
this meme of doctors is walking down a
hall and all these superheroes are
bowing to them and I thought it was
really interesting because bowing isn't
really an American thing it's more of an
Asian thing wouldn't like so I'm
wondering where did this meme come from
and I'm not insinuating anything by it
in terms of who made it I'm just
wondering you know why wouldn't it be
clapping for like somebody was clapping
I wonder if we evolved our bows to nods
well what I mean is it's more subtle now
that it has long been uh wide it's
widely believed that China they have
something called the 50 Cent armies they
propagate us on the internet they get
paid to do it they're the you know
they're widely censored but I think it's
a fair assumption that part of the the
cold war with China is that they're
flooding our social media with divisive
and and you know divisive memes to
create conflict and so so division in
this in this country now the advantage
they have is that they've greatly
censored the internet preventing the US
from doing similarly
we well we're susceptible to it so I'd
imagine over in China they're saying
things like the American people think
they're free they're not there's that
hilarious propaganda video of North
Korea where there are like homeless
people they starve they have no health
care and things like that which are all
technically the truth of course it's way
better here than it is in North Korea
but they highlight the worst or the
worst and claim the worst possible
things are happening and I'd be willing
to bet that for a lot of people in China
they don't know anything about uyghur
Muslims they have no idea it's happening
so their media is all saying we're bad
our media is saying they're bad and here
we are gearing up for some kind of
conflict over Taiwan well for a lot of
like Chinese college students who come
to America like my sister knew a few at
her College they they didn't know what
Tiananmen Square was before they moved
here they didn't know you know they
didn't know about any of you they didn't
know what the Great Leap Forward was how
many people had killed before they came
here it's it's crazy here's Zero Man Pol
Pot Tien squares nuts that was what 1993
when this happened early 90s protest of
college students and like Intelligentsia
came out to protest communism and it was
like Hey we're here now we finally this
is it and they were in the communist
government rolled out tanks and mowed
down crowds of people the Tank Man
pictures like tries to censor it and
like on that day they'll they'll ban
like that word from different uh social
sites and stuff like it's hard to find
it on that day because you can see the
CCP is trying to stop people from
knowing that it happened yeah I'm just
someone super chatted something about
BLM and China we'll read it when we get
to Super chats but I just think it's
gonna be funny when invariably we get
some celebrity or some some athlete in
the at the Olympics who like raises the
red salute and then yells something for
black lives matter in a country that's
for sterilizing minorities it was 1989
Tiananmen Square protests and Massacre
but it's not the first thing that comes
up when you search for it even on
DuckDuckGo it's brutal man I mean I
guess it's it's today tianmen Square
hotels you know but I I I think uh
people might view this as pessimistic I
don't think it's so pessimistic but I
think China's gonna win
why do you mean win they're gonna
they're gonna become the dominant Global
superpower all the contraries will
become deferential to China instead of
the U.S China will expand military bases
they already are all over all over the
planet and then the United States will
be kind of much more like Russia so our
cost of living will go up dramatically
you know will probably bring more labor
and and project and products will be
manufactured in the U.S but life will
generally get harder for most Americans
I don't think that's a bad thing
I think uh American gluttony is
resulting in this like Lost Generation
uh the millennial generation are the
softest of soft we've seen in a long
time and that's probably why we're you
know the fourth turning stress out
generational Theory it's probably why
things are getting bad in the first
place these are people who don't work
don't want to work complain about the
little work they have to do and demand
the government pay them free you know
just give them money for no reason the
money comes out of the pockets of those
who actually do work sorry but if you
live in New York and you work for
BuzzFeed you're not actually producing
anything of value to society and and for
that matter I'll be completely real and
say I know a lot of people like this
show but damn sometimes I'm surprised
that we sit around a table talking about
our thoughts and feelings and we make
more money than a plumber does plumber
actually makes sure your poop goes away
that's in many ways the collective work
of Trades groups electricians machinists
as people noted before substantially
more value than even than even what we
do to be fair to us I understand that
defending you know Liberty freedom and
supporting the working class who are
actually making everything possible is
still a good thing and it's important to
have you know a culture that that
surround you know maintains these values
and ideas but man we sure got a whole
lot of Millennials who do literally
nothing and complain about everything
it's also Gen X a lot of people it's the
gut biome I think has destroyed
motivation people yeah same gluttony too
much of that gunk in your gut and you
just you get up and it's like I'm tired
I'm I I don't know I'm bored you don't
understand that boredom is not boredom
is not supposed to happen everything is
so stimulating clear your gut and you'll
see it
well I mean I would I I think it's more
of a willpower thing people are so well
fed that they don't really have to
hunger and they don't really Chase
things or seek out goals the way people
of the past didn't Ian I sort of hear
what you're saying I wouldn't put it
exactly that way I wouldn't say that
boredom isn't supposed to happen I would
say that it's something we're supposed
to allow to happen so that we can find
interesting things to focus on rather
than just looking at our smartphone or
seeing what's on television or browsing
the internet boredom boredom shouldn't
exist yeah when you're calm in your it's
the most relaxing thing if thoughts are
an annoyance at that point well no I
mean I think that we should allow for
moments of boredom to come because
that's when creativity really starts to
flourish you start coming up with ideas
on your own or figuring out things to do
if every time that boring starts to kick
in you look at your phone and start
strolling you're never gonna be I don't
think you're talking about boredom I
think you're talking about listlessness
or laziness how do you define relaxation
yeah I would Define boredom as
when I think almost by definition it's
when you you aren't sure what to focus
on or nothing is grabbing your attention
I would say boredom is when nothing is
grabbing your attention I think that's a
fair way of defining it I'm never bored
I have never I I think I think sometimes
I think sometimes it's it's good to
allow yourself to be in a situation
where you're not sure what to focus on
because that means you're not looking at
all the traditional things that are
grasping for your attention at all times
and you're looking you're trying to find
something deeper like you could be in a
position where you're not focusing on
anything but not be bored there's a
point I would like to make it's like yes
affordable boredom in my opinion is a
result of it's It's luxury it's luxury
based stagnation it's that we we live in
such luxury that people can sit there
and be like I have literally nothing to
do
well if you have a mission if you have
drive and you have purpose you literally
will never experience that but for so
many people they have no purpose boredom
arises what do I do now I got off work I
have money for my bills my rent is paid
what do I do Consortium yeah put
something in my stomach and then not
have to create something because I I'm
busy digesting yeah they're they're I
have down time down time is like man I'm
exhausted you know so I'll I'll here's
what I did today I woke up immediately
got to work finished work around two
immediately skated for two hours ate
food and set and then sat for about an
hour or so to try and just like rest not
boredom exhaustion then I get cleaned up
to come on the show and here we are on
the show once again we're going to
finish a show and then I'm gonna go to
bed then I'm gonna wake up and do it all
over again there's no on the weekends
it's relaxation not boredom it's like I
need to chill wow man I am wiped out
yeah I guess maybe we're defining the
term differently or maybe we disagree
but I think a little bit of Bourne movie
now again is healthy I bet we're
slightly defining it yeah that could be
be possible boredom to me is usually
when someone like you said I don't know
what to do and you're sitting there
confused they're not sure what to focus
on yeah or or the things that you should
be doing are not immediately obvious to
you and I think so often when people get
that first dose of boredom their
instinct is to run to some form of
entertainment I want to look at my phone
I want to look at my computer I want to
see what's on television instead of
sitting there and going why don't I
imagine a story why don't I start
picking at a guitar why don't I learn an
instrument or a hobby or something along
those lines you see that's
for for someone like me
I've I've had you know I've been bored
before for to you know to a certain
degree but for the most part I probably
experienced substantially left boredom
and I think that's something you get
when you're a kid I think it's something
you you know if you grow up with no
purpose and no meaning you're probably
going to find yourself bored very very
often unsure of what to do with yourself
for me it was too much to do all the
time I played music I skateboarded I was
constantly reading the news I was
constantly learning I used to do flash
animations I used to make websites I was
always just trying to do something
understand something or solve something
what kind of what does your diet like do
you guys eat a lot of sugar growing up
oh I had a lot of candy but was it was
it allowed to have soda in the house did
we yeah yeah we had Fresca oh and then
we had Royal Crown Cola because that was
RC way better than Pepsi Royal clowns
Royal clown world yeah it was kind of
banned from our house my mom wouldn't
let us have soda in the house so at the
time I hated it because I always wanted
sugar sugar and I go to the drug mart
and get sugar and like uh lemon heads
and you know spree and all this but I
had not having in my diet helped me in
later life I'm I used to make video
games on uh back in the day I was I
would do some flash programming I would
do some uh there was a thing called
click and play used to exists and games
Factory and then multimedia Fusion I use
those but then so when I wasn't doing
that I was playing Magic the Gathering I
was playing Pokemon I was skateboarding
so I was literally always doing
something just like there was never a
period of where I wasn't doing anything
we weren't well off by any means my
skateboard was always like you'll get
worn down and then I'd be riding a
crusty board for a while and then I
didn't have the best best cards ever so
it became really hard to be competitive
in any of these things like magic or
whatever but I was always doing
something it was there was always
somewhere to be and then if I wasn't
doing those things there was like just
people to hang out with to talk about
and so we were always off on adventures
I gotta say I think skateboarding is one
of the most powerful things you can do
for a kid because when I first started
skating first of all gives you driving
direction you've got something to
accomplish it's tangible it's in front
of you you know how to do it you've seen
people do it now you need to accomplish
it you get it what's the next step then
what happens is there's fears to
overcome dropping it on a half pipe is
scary but you have to do it and you're
gonna fall the first time not everybody
but 95 chance you're gonna fall and get
hurt and you have to if you want to
overcome that hurdle then the other
thing that skateboarding does is we
started exploring me and all my friends
would travel around going to different
neighborhoods trying to find new places
to skate meeting new people expanding
our reach throughout the city then
eventually I went to other cities and
suburbs and other states and then
traveled around the country outside
Adventure that's a big part of it being
in nature I think Andrew huberman he's a
neuroscientist was saying every human
should at least for 15 minutes a day
gaze into the Horizon it does something
to the brain he explains it way better
than I do but I suggest checking out
Andrew huberman he's a genius he has a
great podcast on YouTube
outdoor activity and also hanging from
branches apparently is very good for
your balance according to Ben Stewart I
know that it's such a boomer thing to
say but the only reason it's a boomer
thing to say is because every generation
before them said it and it's like one of
the wise things they actually retained
but kids just don't spend enough time
outside anymore and it's sad because
what you're talking about going out and
exploring with your friends I did
similar things and we were fortunate
because our parents didn't really want
us to have game systems we didn't get
them until we were a bit older we didn't
have cable in our house so we pretty
much had to go outside and find things
to do I knew so many kids in my
generation and especially in the
generation a little bit after me where
the kids kind of didn't really develop a
personality because all they were doing
was focusing on electronics and I'm not
saying that you can't develop skills or
some personality with electronics either
you know you like you said you can learn
to code you can learn to build computers
that's all really productive but it's
just sad that this sense of exploration
has been lost because so many kids will
just find it in their video game system
or nowadays in their smartphone well
something something that was I think
really good for me growing up is I was
an athlete I think sports are a really
important thing that you can that you
can do for a kid you know it's it
teaches teamwork you know you're working
towards a goal of winning with a bunch
of people you meet friends that way like
so for me that was something that I
think really helped me it also teaches
you a lot of like you know values of
hard work you know working hard to get
to the highest level in your sport and I
think you know I think the world would
be a better place if we had if we had a
lot of athletes well yeah I think that's
interesting and one more thing I want to
point out here which is is different
between the time and I know we're not
all the same age but the times
respectively that we were all raised in
and how kids are being raised now is
even though we did have all sorts of you
know distracting electronic gadgets at
least when you were outside you were
outside now with these smartphones
they're constantly online even when
they're Outdoors it's a very unhealthy
thing like they don't get to take a
break from that technology
infrastructure the way we could when we
were kids you could just kind of go out
into the woods or go into the forest or
go to your local pond with your siblings
and really be in nature and that's not
possible anymore because they always
have everything at their fingertips I
wonder if the Wi-Fi is agitating people
too that might have some the countries
in this upcoming Civil War the barriers
the borders
they're digital
that's why you know Bill Maher was like
you know we can't have a civil war
because the Mason-Dixon Line would go
through Nana's Kitchen so well sure
people are now polarizing based on the
ideology they hold based on digital
boundaries so there are bubbles on
Twitter there's a left bubble and a
right bubble and you can actually map it
out there's been these really great
visualizations showing how they like
they they like Clash and then spread out
and you have like the right which is
mostly the far right it's all like
destroyed and banned so you have like
this big clump of like center right and
then you have this huge splash of far
left those are the borders of the
upcoming or the current cold civil war
Civil whatever we're going to call it
well I I find that fascinating because
there is an old George George Bernard
Shaw quote he said the class Warfare of
the future will be fought between
competing intellectual classes for The
Souls of our children
that's great when did he make that quote
do you have anything I'm not sure that's
awesome that's true no there you go man
when you were talking about sports and
how great they are I had an experience
where when I was a kid in fifth grade I
used to play sports soccer and baseball
and then my mom put me in baseball in
fifth grade but which they didn't do I
was like can I go practice batting cage
and we don't have the money sorry so I
couldn't practice and so putting a kid
in sport but not
putting them in a place to practice the
sport was very embarrassing for me
because I didn't know how to play
baseball and I was the worst kid on the
team and my friends turned their backs
on me so it was really ostracizing
what's the thing about skateboarding is
that skate parks are typically free up
into the public and there's tons of
people there to hang out with yeah it's
more of a free easy to practice sport
yep
yeah I mean I get that like it's not
obviously if you're if your kid doesn't
like it or you know he doesn't enjoy it
then it's not I actually really enjoyed
it yeah um just a shout out to all you
parents out there if you're gonna put
your kids in sports make sure you get
them training put them in training as
well it's just as important as the
performance
all right let's read uh let's read super
chats if you haven't already smash that
like button one like is one hunk go to
timcast.com become a member we have a
members only segment coming up for you
around 11 or so p.m don't want to miss
those and uh as I I think I said
subscribe to this channel so all right
let's read some more
all right I can't read the name of the
first Super chatter because
YouTube blocks it off for some reason
but they said the blockade and our
legislative building in Regina
Saskatchewan I was not uh I was not
there but last night a crazy amount of
police cleared them out I'm yet to go by
today how sad
crazy
Christopher Chapman says I love big
Honkers but seriously how can you ban
honking screw these monsters time for a
Canadian Revolution
well the people of Canada are standing
up for themselves and non-violent civil
disobedience is working beautifully I
just refreshed Twitter in the first
tweet is honk
the cure for a clown world was honking
that's so ridiculous who would have
thought that honking could bring so many
people together yeah man
happy Canuck says in Ontario honking at
random was already illegal to do it is
in the traffic act and counts as
aggressive driving in Chicago it's
improper use of horn
so if you just honk randomly then give
you a ticket for it I guess
William Leverett says the trucker
protest is safe and effective well all
right then
Athen says I want to give a shout out to
Otto walks on YouTube he is he is a
walking live streamer who has become
even more popular during the honking he
crossed paths with Eva fry today as well
viva's great
and uh shout out to Ottawa do you guys
know any other good streamers that are
up there covering we are all the rebel
news guys for sure the rebel news guys
have done the best job there are a bunch
of hot dogs in the chat where people are
posting hot dogs and then saying
Portland Andy is he what's what's left
there he's just live streaming he's not
a Portland Andy he's he's not wait he's
not where he's not in Ottawa just lives
should be the coverage I think he's not
in Ottawa he's just live streaming the
coverage oh okay so he's not on the
ground yeah oh
so who's he like he's like picking up
other people's streams or something I
don't know kind of rakita lying it keep
allowing it maybe yeah Ethan says Ian
you rolled a one when you were doing
your introduction but here is a 20 for
Spiritual mind drugs because I love you
thank you so much
Archer meguire says the Canadian goose
is my favorite Pokemon
no it's a sticker I want a shirt of it
I'll wear it Jessica you hear me I think
it is honka boot Hunker Boot and find
out yeah I love it Michael says I'm an
OTR driver and trainer most company
drivers like myself can't get to the
protest really wish you can get an
active driver to come on lots of the
public doesn't get it Blow the train
horns
all right Cyrus says they can shut down
tens of thousands of protesters but they
can't shut down Millions stand up for
your rights because no one else will
keep up the good work fellas and Lady
definitely
oh here we go
P diddle says flashing your headlights
warn of cops ahead is protected by the
First Amendment oh that's interesting
but is it a civil offense then or
something
yeah because I've heard people could get
pulled over for that maybe because it's
supposedly it's disrupting traffic maybe
that's why they pull it over
I don't know man the the dangerous thing
about a Cop trying to claim your honking
was improper or whatever
it's like how do how do they prove
exactly with a radar detector with a
radar gun they can be like you were
going seven miles an hour over the limit
that's a speeding ticket and then you go
to court and they say like here's the
readout your honor it's like he was
speeding and then you know now they have
dash cams and all that stuff
but if they were like he uses horn
improperly I'd be like oh there was a
fox also how can they get scared out of
the way but I want to hit it it's like
unless they have footage they can't even
prove that you honked at all yeah I
guess with the wrong body cameras yeah
people are saying now that apparently
they're going to go around with empty
gas cans all over the place so the cops
are forced to stop everybody but they
don't have anything brilliant they
always find a way man it's like the
plants growing up out of the concrete
yep it's just it's like it's like you
remember I forget what European country
this happened in but there was like some
European like City that banned fireworks
and there was like this video that went
really viral on Twitter just like a
millions of fireworks going into the air
in the city oh yeah I think
La I think Band Fire Works on the fourth
of July yeah and then people were flying
in there fireworks there were so many
last time I was there that's what you
need to understand they want you they
want to convince you
that the small Fringe minority of eight
percent is the 90 but I'll tell you this
they're saying the same thing about the
truckers that they're a fringe minority
yeah that's the biggest trucker Convoy
the world has ever seen and when you see
them ban fireworks and then a plane is
coming in and everyone's lighting them
off yo
you are with the majority the government
is lying to you
unrealized potential says silence is
violence in the honk is the way oh I
like you
Raymond loera says bring back the soccer
vuvuzelas
remember those Booboo zealas they're the
big horns and they're my and everybody
was blowing them all the time look it up
yeah Vuvu Zella those got banned from
everywhere yeah
people were blowing those horns
Murph says Ian the truckers Mega horn
Comet totally made me think of the Power
Rangers Vehicles Hong Kong yeah it's
like burning man too you start to you'll
hear 10 000 radios all blasting it once
it becomes one song
all right let's see we got
Patricia says can they be prosecuted if
they record honking and play it on a
loudspeaker not honking right I mean
that's really interesting what if what
if they record what if someone just
writes a song that has a bunch of
honking in it and the song is just
really really low but the honking is
really really loud in the U.S you need a
permit to do uh to use a megaphone or
audio any kind of electrical audio
equipment in New York I don't know about
Canadian law interesting rylo says like
it or not everyone is in this fight over
Freedom Rogan knew the rules took aside
and capitulated where folks with less
security put everything on the line and
stood strong your friend is a coward
you know what man uh
I won't I won't look at it like um so
black and white I can only just say if
you're watching this show and you think
we do a good job you can thank Joe Rogan
for helping make this possible and
that's that's the important thing if Joe
decides that he's tired and he's you
know he doesn't want to be involved in
this he's done so much good for
everybody outside of literally helping
us heal from sickness helping you know
having me on his show I understand me
going on a show was good for him too you
know we have guests come on the show
it's good for us it's good for everybody
but uh
I think I think he's done so much good
like I'll put it this way out of 100
good that Joe Rogan has done there's
like in my view like too bad you know
what I mean so it's like I'm not gonna
be mad at the guy he's done like he's
earned so much good will and credit for
me and it sort of strikes me like how
sometimes they'll come up and you'll say
is it worth sacrificing 99 of the things
you can say so you can say that one
thing that's going to get you banned and
it's kind of like Joe he's like I'm not
gonna worry about this one thing it's
not I'm just putting it away because
this other but that's admittedly a
defeat maybe you know what I mean
sometimes sometimes Retreat is the best
option well so the way that's the way I
describe it I'm like you know I tell
people here I've said it on the show if
there's a hundred things I want to say
one of them will get his banned we'll
say the 99 things and then put the one
thing on the website for everyone to to
see or we'll put it up on the podcast
platforms on Sundays or whatever to try
and make sure we're doing something to
get it out we do have a paywall for
member content because the website costs
some money it costs money every time
someone watches a video when we're
trying to grow the operation and do all
that stuff that's just you know business
but uh it's also me basically saying we
have taken from our heap of sand but one
grain and handed it to the other side
and that means if everyone keeps doing
that they eventually win it's not a
winning scenario it's admitting defeat
and explaining why we did so I'm not
happy about it
but well Retreat is different than
defeat you can Retreat and then win
we've seeded certain territories for the
sake of trying to maintain the center
and so sometimes you sacrifice a piece
in chess to try and gain the upper hand
and it works but it's not easy so in
this instance I say the same thing of
Joe I'm not a fan of his I think the
apology will backfire I think it is
backfiring I think it's bad for him
across the board
but it's not you know he can do us
whatever he wants you know I think it
was a mistake I I think it's a mistake
as an apology I think it's a mistake
culturally I think it's a mistake for
the benefit of his business I just don't
see any scenario in which apologizing
will do anything for him if he's upset
that he has friends like Dave Chappelle
and you know they don't like the fact
that he said this word or whatever he
can say it to them but doing the public
statement only makes more people hate
him interesting it makes it worse so
it's like it's like he got a little bit
of taint and now he's going in the water
and and if he puts it out there it's
going to spread out to a bunch of other
stuff I'll put it this way you are
standing on a big stage and there are 11
million people all watching you and
staring at you on the microphone and
then someone right in front of the stage
is holding up a video of you doing awful
things so you look at it take the
microphone and go hey there's a video
right here to everybody who can hear me
of me doing really awful things I'm
sorry I did it and then everyone in the
honest was like whoa we didn't know you
did that
so that's that's the issue with like the
main issue with doing blanket apologies
Joe's voice is louder than the activists
who are smearing him Joe Amplified their
voice with his own multiplying the the
negative impact that's that's you know
I just we're living in social science
right we're doing social science as we
live I love this I think
you know I I think Joe's probably not
even paying attention to a lot of the
stuff I hope not just cool your mind but
yeah I think he's just doing his thing I
wish him all the best man uh and I I I I
feel bad that there's so much
conversation around him that we keep
talking about him because I'm sure it's
annoying
but he's got the biggest podcast in the
world and one of the biggest shows in
history so it's like she's gotta talk
about it you know for sure influencing
everything
Cason Womble says Sheamus your argument
on abortion your vid on freedom Tunes
changed my stance from choice to life
and Tim if companies will turn over
private texts what could Amazon do with
Alexis if they record we got one over
there yelling at Mina they do record
they're recording all the time
um I I believe so in order for
uh a device to be activated by voice the
microphone has to be on
now you understand thank you yeah also I
want to take a moment to respond to that
first of all thank you for that super
chat I very much appreciate that
um I've done a few videos on abortion
I'm glad that one of them
reached you and that you changed your
position and are now fighting for The
Unborn I mean hearing that kind of thing
really really makes this worth it so
genuinely from the bottom of my heart
thank you you know what the video is
I've done a couple on abortions probably
the recent one it's probably the most
recent one where the leftist is calling
the baby a parasite but he's refusing to
get a job oh yeah yes okay yes that was
probably it could have been that one
we'll either way thank you so much I
again massively appreciate it all right
Lucas Parada says Freedom protesters
were arrested for bringing fuel to the
truckers so today most protesters
started carrying around empty gas cans
they are genius that is very very clever
that's very cool yep Nathan Brubaker
says CBC receives 1.5 billion dollars in
taxpayer dollars from the Liberals in
Canada comparisons can be made to North
Korea's Government monopoly on media
yep
that's government-funded media for you
Roberto says word on the internet 4chan
already figured out where Trudeau is
where's that
surprise me trash Panda says Hong Kong
two Canadian Boogaloo we're not your
buddy guy
oh Hong Kong 2 Canadian Boogaloo I get
it I get it
all right
Brado says if kicked out truckers should
simply stop delivering to Ottawa we can
fund their living on give send go yay or
nay what other option is there well
fifty thousand truckers how many
truckers are there
how many truckers work in Canada
500.
100 000 half of them are protesting
says Ambassador Bridge between Detroit
and Canada has been taken over by
protesters oh my yeah so I just saw a
number that in 2018 there were 312 000
truck drivers in Canada up from 55 000
in the year twos 18 years earlier so
from 55 to 312 and 18 years that's up to
2018. Jeff Mark says Tim did you see
Dave Portnoy take down the PAC members
Behind The Joe Rogan video last night
it's all about a power display and
creating value as the most powerful
left-wing character assassins I I saw
that he had posted it Dave Portnoy is a
rad dude as far as I'm concerned and
he's suing the media for smearing him I
think he's fantastic and uh big fan of
Barstool Sports just because they opened
that new bar stool sports book and they
have like good chicken wings over at the
casino oh nice it's really awesome
there's like a gigantic 20-foot screen
be fun to get Dave over here and go to
the casino and do a Barstool thing that
would be Super Rad I would I would uh it
would be Super Rad to have Dave come out
but he's he's a super what a cool dude
famous busy guy what's going on it's so
it's so hilarious and wild to me that
Insider told one of their reporters to
spend eight months interviewing every
single woman that Dave Portnoy has ever
had sex with fine seriously imagine
having to do that you have to track down
every woman that a guy's ever had sex
with you find four three or four however
many ones who didn't even enjoy it but
he didn't do anything wrong and then put
it under a byline that suggests he's a
sexual predator why you know like
imagine are there other stories that you
that could take much of your time other
than this like and and and and portnoy's
basically debunked it all oh yeah he's
published the messages be like look at
them they're begging like I gotta be
honest literally they are yeah there's
messages where they're like I want you
know you know what I'm saying and
they've put all these stories behind
paywalls oh yeah yep so you buy it to
read it and then go oh how stupid but
he's suing him good for him man yeah you
know he said he said a lot of people
have said like why do it he was like
look they're do they've released these
stories right before their earnings
calls for for pen gaming like they're
trying you know what man I would not be
surprised
let's just separate ourselves from that
conversation and just say they're
probably news organizations that will
put you know options or something put
options on stock or short of stock
publish a negative story
oh wow and then profit yup so so you
know it's like federally in 1908 they
would have just been trashed just a
company would have been ripped to shreds
for doing something like that 150 years
ago it's a
isn't there that famous story that uh
like after the Napoleonic Wars or
something that Master the guy like rode
on a horseback to to England with a
message that Napoleon had lost
but then they claimed that Napoleon won
so the stock collapsed it was in England
yeah I know that story I'd have to pull
up the exact yeah I heard like this has
been happening for a long time bro like
they spread the war that Napoleon won so
everyone was selling off everything like
crazy rich people bought it up for super
cheap and then the actual award got out
Napoleon lost and then everything
skyrocketed in value
okay I'll fight I'll see if I can find I
was reading something about that I don't
know what that I don't know if that's
true or not or just you know something
like something that would happen Maybe
yeah it'd be Super Rad to have uh Dave
Portnoy and I don't know if he's too
busy but uh you know as this show gets
bigger we're getting more and more uh
interest from from more and more famous
people so that's cool that's why I'm
here I know yeah it was really hard to
book Sheamus Freedom Tunes over here
yeah Joe says Joe Rogan Rumble my dwack
stonks is gonna Moon
but I don't think Rumble is dweck it's
that other thing what is it CVI or
something clvi or something like that
dwac is a trump Swan right yeah
Perry says just finished Rogan's episode
with Jordan Peterson it's crazy how jbp
almost foreshadows what was about to
happen to Joe hoping Joe ends up
following the advice Peterson gave him
certainly
certainly certainly
zero Safar says Ian these people chose
to live in the capital where protests
will happen would you feel bad for
people that chose to make a home next to
an active volcano then complain that
there are lava that that that there is a
lava that makes their life hard a very
good point I was watching video of of a
simulation of what it would have been
like in uh what's that volcano yeah and
Pompeii the day of the eruption and you
can just watch it and it's on YouTube
actually there's like a long 20-minute
simulation of like a day in Pompeii when
it goes did they all instantly die from
the miracastic flow not all of them uh
it's sort of the heat the glasses the
singing smoke came down and started a
coat and burn everyone but one guy like
I think it was Pliny the Elder had left
the city but he came back by boat to
rescue his family and when he got back
to the city he got killed by the volcano
so they they mostly didn't get soaked up
in lava wasn't it it was pyroclastic
covered by Flash oh yeah it's the it's
this it's the shock wave of hot gases
that spray out and sweets and then hit
you and then you can't breathe and then
you burn and then die oh man I think
that's what it was what a city I had my
parents got to visit I want to go there
someday remember when that activation
wasn't there like a volcano eruption in
New Zealand or something and a bunch of
people got like vaporized or some crazy
whatever no oh I found some of this info
on the Napoleonic uh defeat British in
Paris after defeat of the point it's
1815. I'm not gonna go into it too long
right now but if you guys want to look
it up history of banking 1815 Napoleon I
think you'll find it there but what
happened uh well I gotta I gotta read
more let me tell you about it tomorrow
all right I'll bring it let me come back
with it
legendary Aces have you ever seen
psychopass it's an anime in a dystopia
where your latent criminality is tracked
by your thoughts and actions if you're
deemed a criminal enforcers will be sent
after you yikes it's all it's a Minority
Report
good movie too yeah well it was a fellow
okay dick short story wasn't it
the breakout don't snow
they can they can arrest you for a crime
you did not yet commit exciting the
narcoleptic rant says Tim cats is my
birthday and I released a song y'all
might like the bear shelves Biden Blues
keep up the great work right on so I
played that will of the people game itch
dot IO will the people someone mentioned
that they'd made the game it's actually
really clever it's it's pretty good it's
uh there are three factions and you're
trying to propagandize and manipulate
people into gaining power and then when
you finally gain power the wheel rotates
and then your faction takes over and
then you can do marches and like you
know propagandize and stuff so you're
like trying to figure out how to get the
highest score I'm gonna tell you I'm
gonna tell you about this Napoleon thing
get it out of the way for as long this
is uh it's called the Napoleon is dead
the great Stock Exchange fraud of 1814
and then this is from the
historypress.co.uk for as long as
they've existence existed stock markets
have attracted fraudsters early Stock
Exchange scam involving one of the great
semen of the age Lord Cochrane is a
powerful and fascinating tale of greed
deceit and public humiliation in
February 1814 news arrived in Dover that
the French had been defeated in Napoleon
killed by the time the London Stock
Exchange opened the city was full of
rumors of a great Allied Victory the
price of government bonds Rose so
rapidly in a Syndicate of speculators
took the opportunity to offload it its
recent acquired Holdings at highly
favorable prices but this was this was
before he was defeated or this is the
yeah they said they spread a rumor that
he'd been defeated and killed and all
the value started to go up and then they
sold off yep and then he'd actually won
and they found out he was alive and all
the prices dropped back down but they
would already back up so it was the
opposite of what I was saying and then
he eventually decided to uh invade
Russia in the winter and you know we
know how that works out for people yeah
don't do that I like this meme people
are like there's a war about to break
out with Ukraine and Russia and the U.S
ascending soldiers and someone tweeted
is Russia good at winter War
there was a I saw a really great tweet
from uh his name's Oren McIntyre I don't
think I don't know if I'm pronouncing
that right but he tweeted after failing
in Afghanistan the graveyard of Empires
the ruling class has turned their
attention to fighting a war in Russia in
the winter yeah that's a great plan
brilliant rylo says Rogan most
definitely took a side against cancel
culture he laid it all out when he had
Alex Jones on his show you are biased
because he helped you I'm I'm confused
by what that means though like you're
saying he opposes cancel culture I've
I've seen clips of Joe and I've seen
enough of his show to to think that he
understands apologizing doesn't work and
I think he's even talked about it before
so I don't know I don't think how my
bias
because Joe helped me would make me
critical of him the bias would make me
be like Joe can do no wrong
but I wouldn't say that if anybody
we all have the demon within us
Mick Chilla says if Joe thinks he's
protecting his show by censoring himself
he's delusional his fan base will drop
quicker than FB stock if he continues to
bend the knee to the establishment
I I'm gonna say this you know I think
back to when uh I was just in my living
room in the Philadelphia suburbs I had
two YouTube channels it was before I
went on Joe's show I had 180 000 Subs I
was making good money I had a I had a I
had a I was making a good amount of
money on my own just doing like you know
three videos or four videos per day
where I was like reading the news in the
morning I would be done by about 3 P.M
I'd have the rest of the day to do my
thing and you know we'd go out to get
pizza and we'd hang out skate in the
back and then play Magic the Gathering
and then I was like let's do more work
let's do a lot more work and now all of
a sudden I have we have this show which
is way bigger than I ever thought it was
going to be this show is way bigger than
my main Channel which went from you know
it's 10 times bigger than it than it
than it you know than it was before
so now this show has grown so large
we're getting swatted we're getting
ddosed we have all this crazy business
expansion we have employees and I'm just
like
I wonder if Joe is just sitting there
thinking like
dude I just want to smoke weed with my
friends and talk about aliens like this
is he does that anyway yeah but I'm just
like at a certain point he might just be
saying what is going on like why I never
wanted to do this on your show and
interview him he hasn't done a lot of
interviews lately it'd be good it's too
busy man come on maybe now's the time he
popped in when we were in Austin but you
know he's a busy guy so you know what
man
part of me thinks there's there's a lot
of there's there's a lot there's a lot
of philosophy a lot of people say Mo
Money Mo Problems a lot of people uh you
know say like money won't make you happy
and stuff like that there's a fine
balance between being a psychotic
workahol a workaholic you know like me
and then kind of just accepting when you
have a good salary and just having time
to you know play with like play games
card games with your friends and work on
side projects and just chill and then
I've just been like literally I feel
like
if I if I if I I can't it's pain for me
to stop for it's painful for me to stop
moving you'd be a good dad
it is painful for me to stop working
good because kids need your constant
attention yeah I guess man
but I I I look Sub sub constant like Joe
Rogan
he could stop at any time and like why
isn't he there's a reason why he's so
rich and successful is because he can't
he can't stop he's got to keep going
he's got to keep making it happen I
wonder if at a certain point everybody
reaches that retirement age where
they're just like I'm done
you know I fought the the battle and now
it's time to just chill and go fishing
and raise my kids and play some music
yeah like the stones are still touring
that's pretty badass I don't know yeah
man I guess what do you call retiring
what you love the Mick Jagger also like
a couple years ago had a baby with a 29
year old at the age of like 70 however
old he is now whoa pretty impressive
yeah Clint Eastwood did that too I think
maybe not 29 year old I'm not sure
because young kids oh this is
interesting Derek Curtis says JP Sears
and Zion just offered Joe Rogan 100
million in Bitcoin to join them do they
have 100 million in Bitcoin
depends on where the market's at I guess
they're just hoping it goes back up
here's the crazy thing if you told me JP
Sears was worth 70 million dollars
because he had Bitcoin I'd be like wow
I know a lot of people who bought a
bunch of Bitcoin when it was worth
nothing I know and it's like 10 years
later they're billionaires yeah the
money is out of control if you really
understood how billionary people got
it's a millionaire before it was even
taxed my story is that I wanted to buy 7
000 like 500 Bitcoin in 2011 and my
friend told me not to do it because it
was like worthless you couldn't do
anything with it and I was like yeah
sure fine you know you're probably right
and then when it hit five bucks I was
like no because like it went from
seventy five bucks yeah anymore I lost
seven thousand it was like 7 333 Bitcoin
or something like that imagine if I had
that much Bitcoin I actually thought
when ethereum was 10 bucks that I'd
missed the boat and it was too expensive
to get ten dollars I didn't realize at
the time the incremental purchase power
it's just more about the percentage of
the increase and how much of a
percentage of your wealth you put into
it when when ethereum was at 100 bucks I
was like damn missed that one but then I
had this revelation
I was just sitting there and I was like
every single time I say to myself that
bitcoin's too expensive I realized as an
idiot and it's going to keep getting
more and more valuable so then when
Bitcoin was at like a thousand I bought
a bunch
but a bunch is like like literally like
a bunch like a small bundle that you
could hold in your hands like not that
much and so I got a good amount of
crypto for sure you know but uh I wish I
bought in 2011. no dude I know and I was
like very this is back in my libertarian
era and so many of my fans were all into
Bitcoin like I am absolutely one of the
people who should have known I was like
nah it's gonna crash like I just didn't
know anything about it but you know the
craziest thing is the people I know who
became ultra wealthy of it are some of
the dumbest people I've ever met because
the issue was when I was having
conversations with my friends about
Bitcoin we were talking about the
potential pitfalls there's there's like
hard forking was a problem hard forking
uh I'm sorry I'm sorry not not hard
forking but forking in general when
there have been a few instances where
Bitcoin accidentally by error split into
two different Bitcoins and then this had
to like there was like an emergency like
okay well that's the real one and they
did like switch back to the proper fork
and so we were like that's possible when
when like when the when the network is
too small
it can Branch off and to create two
different networks I don't agree with
each other and ignore each other and
clash and so we were like there's some
issues there there's issues with
cracking cryptography and things like
that and then I know people who are
alike the government is awful this is
not government money I'm buying it and
I'm like you got to think about this I'm
like no and they bought a ton and now
they're all original yeah I think
sometimes when I'm investing I think too
far ahead and I got to remember I'm
playing with the lowest common
denominator I have to buy the stuff that
most people are gonna bite at even
though the stuff that's better might not
get popular until later so you got to
kind of almost dumb yourself down to
make money in the investment Market
in a way
more about reading people
all right Ryan says if you got a problem
with Canada gooses then you've got a
problem with me letter Kenny I don't
know who that is letter Kenny's a TV
show it's a really really funny TV show
well all right
a true free thinker says those that
carry empty gas cans in Ottawa are like
those that were on on Thomas Crown
Affair wearing the baller hats and
carrying briefcases you are all
fantastic you ever see that Thomas Crown
Affair I think so it's where he's like
stealing the painting and then like
there's a ton of people who all look
exactly like him running around and the
cops don't know which one is which and
who to get yeah that's uh what's his
name's in that Bond
all right
David says don't forget Joe has a wife
and kids he has to think about them too
it's not just him for sure
but you know how much money is enough
money here yeah but it just shows not
about money it's it's never it's not
it's about you just can't stop you know
I don't I don't think they're gonna
starve I don't yeah it's about Capital
which is people's uh willingness to work
with you and the amount of money you can
acquire but usually the money's used to
get Capital they call money Capital but
it really doesn't have any value until
you transact it all right
groins says Hi I went to the honking in
Ottawa on Saturday wearing my step-on
snack shirt and found Viva live
streaming sent an email to pitches it
was the step on snack and find out shirt
you saw that video yeah we saw it yeah
we saw it oh sweet yeah so so I will I
will say this
step on snack and find out was our
fastest selling t-shirt
it was ridiculous and then we made the
free honk honk Flag t-shirt and that is
now our fastest selling t-shirt it's
crazy we've sold many many of those so
my friends if you haven't already smash
that like button one like is one honk
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and go to timcast.com
become a member we are going to start
recording our members only podcast for
all of you it'll be up around 11 or so
p.m tonight you don't want to miss it
you can follow us at timcastirl on
Instagram for Clips you can follow me at
timcast on Instagram Twitter wherever uh
you want to shout anything out Greg
um no just I'm Greg underscore price 11.
um let's go win in 20 let's go win in
November right on awesome well first I
have to correct uh a bit of non-medical
misinformation for myself earlier in the
show right after I said it I realized it
but the conversation moved on I I
mentioned Nazi Germany ending in the
late 40s it was the mid 40s yeah and
none of you corrected late 45 of you but
yeah but that's not like the late 40s
what was it no it was early it was early
40s
mid mid we'll go with mid I wasn't that
wrong
um but yeah I just want to plug Freedom
Tunes it's the cartoon channel that I
run we release a video every single week
on Thursdays we're also going to be
releasing a video tomorrow about the Joe
Rogan controversy just a short little
tune that Tim did a voice for it was
wonderful and I think you'll all enjoy
it very much and then we have a video
coming out on Thursday as well two this
week crazy I know that you know you guys
have your your position for me over at
Freedom Tunes but I'm telling you man I
can do more just give me the opportunity
for more characters man just just coming
on a little strong you're coming on a
little strong I've been Typecast
you do a great job with fauci all right
I'm leaving it there hey Lydia is it
true that you created the honka Boot and
fine dude that's correct that was my
idea that is amazing I know you're very
creative no but you've done other voices
besides fauci yeah sjw and uh the police
officer but it's almost more fun to just
let people figure out because a lot of
times not everyone watches the credits I
don't know so but it'll say it in there
and so people are like I can't believe
Tim did that boys I don't think I'm good
police officer was uh are you kidding me
yeah thank you well then I'll give the
job to someone else you need like an
older Gruff guy that's you you're you're
you're so Gruff and older no you do a
good job you do a good job voicing the
police officer I thought so but if you
want to talk yourself out of job you're
just telling me that you do more of the
fouching as soon as I put on another
roll you do you're like
what I never said but that means you're
hired for more because you're honest
about your limitations
the faucy bobble head by the way I don't
think I saw the Vlog but uh Luke Luke
had his way with it and then fixed an
animal
he's a wild thing he's a crazy he's a
wild one no we were he and I were on the
Vlog and he's sitting there blaming
China as he holds Tim's shattered faucy
bobble head rapping I'm actually mad
about that yeah I thought it wasn't cool
he's like too much stuff where one goes
too you know so Ian gave me a fouchy
bobble head Luke broke it trying to put
the gorilla on him and I was like yo
glue his legs back together it's like
this is our fouchy we like we Bobble his
head and so instead Luke just broke it
more yeah and then he leaves help
himself it's like rapid a truth tape
yeah uh I just replaced it I just popped
up Twitter Tim Dylan definitely canceled
the Olympics forever it was cool now
it's dumb enough yes correct from the
words of God to you through Tim Dylan
just want to let everyone know Tim's one
of my favorite guys I love that guy uh
Hey follow me at Ian crossland.net
transition this off and about to Lydia I
love you all and I'll see you later
thank you I also want to correct my own
little bit of misinformation earlier
when we were talking about bones in the
leg the tibia is a larger bone on the
inside of the leg the fibula is a
smaller one on the outside of fibia is a
combination of those two words that is
so I was right shameful it was tibia
tibia is the the bone on the outside of
the leg I was I was right yeah you were
right yeah so when we came up with a
fibia you see that's not it's the
problem with with accepting that you're
wrong and being unsure of yourself
because if I was just confident and
arrogant like nope I'm right don't care
don't know I'm confident
what was I thinking yeah but yeah I just
want to correct that because I saw
somebody mention that and I was like
that doesn't sound quite right I just
couldn't remember it from Anatomy anyway
you guys should follow me on Twitter and
mines at Sour Patch let's we will see
all of you every single one of you now
all 35 000 are still watching go to
timcast.com become members we're gonna
have that members only segment for you
tonight and we'll see y'all there bye
guys